l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion du
projet de loi de finances considéré
comme adopté par l'Assemblée nationale
en application de l'article 49 alinéa 3
de la Constitution pour 2024 dans la
discussion générale la parole est à
Monsieur Bruno Le Maire ministre de
l'économie des finances et de la
souveraineté industrielle et
numérique monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Président de la commission des
finances monsieur le rapporteur général
monsieur le ministre cher Thomas CASNAV
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs vous
permettrez d'abord d'abord de saluer
dans cette hémicycle la présence de
Raphaël Zairi qui m'accompagne dans le
cadre de la Semaine européenne pour
l'emploi des personnes handicapées vous
savez à quel point nous tenons avec le
gouvernement et toute la majorité et je
pense toutes les sénatrices et tous les
sénateurs présents à l'insertion des
personnes en situation de handicap dans
le monde du travail donc je veux dire à
Raphaël et à travers lui à toutes les
personnes porteuses d'un handicap vous
avez toute votre place et vous devez
avoir toute votre place dans notre
société compte sur notre engagement
total en la matière mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs je m'exprime
devant vous sur le budget
2024 dans une période économique
complexe chacun voit que la conjoncture
internationale
ralentit chacun voit que plusieurs de
nos partenaires y compris les plus
proches connaissent un ralentissement de
leur croissance et que certains sont
même confrontés à la
récession chacun mesure également que
même si l'inflation reflu elle continue
de pénaliser de compatriotes en
particulier les plus modestes malgré les
mesures qui ont été prises ces derniers
mois et malgré le début de
ralentissement des prix enfin chacun
voit que des inquiétudes fortes sont
nées de la situation au Proche Orient et
de la persistance de la guerre en
Ukraine
dans cette période difficile je veux
redire ma confiance dans la capacité de
l'économie française à tenir bon et à
dégager des perspectives positives pour
l'avenir premier constat nous avons de
la croissance ça n'est pas le cas
partout en Europe ça n'est pas le cas
partout dans la zone euro nous ferons
comme je m'y été engagé 1 % de
croissance en 2023 et la Commission
européenne vient de réévaluer la
croissance française pour 202 4 à 1,2 %
en rapprochant donc son évaluation de
l'estimation du gouvernement à 1,4 %.
enfin l'inflation reflu en France elle
reflu dans la zone euro nous sommes donc
en train de gagner la bataille contre
l'inflation en un peu moins de 2 ans là
où dans les années 70 confronté à une
situation similaire nous avions mis 10
ans à sortir de la crise
inflationniste l'emploi marque certes le
pas mais nous avons encore des
perspectives de création d'emploi
dynamique pour les années qui viennent
avec des projets industriels majeurs à
réaliser j'ai donc la conviction absolue
que si nous prenons les bonnes décisions
dans les mois qui viennent si nous
poursuivons les transformations
économiques nécessaires si nous
indispensables de notre modèle social
pour inciter davantage au retour à
l'emploi la France réussira dans les les
prochaines décennies encore faut-il je
le dis tenir une ligne de très grande
clarté et de très grande
fermeté d'abord une ligne de très grande
clarté et de très grande fermeté sur les
comptes publics ce projet de loi de
finances garantit un déficit de 4,4 %
pour 2024 avec Thomas CASNAV nous
tiendrons ces 4,4 % de déficit pour
2024 nous avons toujours tenu nos
objectifs de déficit àex exception de la
période exceptionnelle du covid je tiens
ce que notre parole reste la même avec
la même crédibilité pour les années qui
viennent nous tiendrons ces 4,4 % et la
réduction la dépense publique qui va
avec en premier lieu en sortant des
boucliers tarifèire sur l'électricité et
sur le gaz je rappelle que nous
continuons à payer aujourd'hui plus de
30 % de la facture d'électricité des
ménages et que nous continuons donc à
protéger nos compatriotes contre le
l'augmentation des prix de l'électricité
mais dès lors que nous revenons à la
normale il me paraît légitime
d'abandonner progrressivement les
dispositifs de soutien aussi bien pour
les entreprises que pour les ménages
c'est fait pour le bouclier sur le gaz
et nous le ferons d'ici le 1er janvier
2025 pour le bouclier sur
l'électricité l'excellent rapporteur
général Jean-François Husson a proposé
d'accélérer la sortie du bouclier
électricité
je veux le remercier d'avoir fait cette
proposition je pense que c'est une bonne
proposition une proposition utile
intéressante et justifié nous sommes
prêts à la reprendre dès lors que pour
les ménages les tarifs n'augmentent pas
de plus de 10 % en février 2024 c'est un
engagement que j'ai pris et j'aime bien
tenir mes engagements vis-à-vis de nos
compatriotes ma proposition serait donc
de reprendre la suggestion du rapporteur
général Jean-François Husson tout en
expliquant très clairement que
l'augmentation des prix de l'électricité
ne pourra pas dépasser 10 % en février
2024 j'ajoute que toujours dans ce
budget nous ferons aussi des économies
sur la politique de l'emploi et sur le
retrait des dispositifs à destination
des
entreprises le deuxième moyen de
respecter cette réduction de la dépense
publique c'est les revues de dépenses
qui ont été voulu par la première
ministre et mis en œuvre depuis
maintenant plusieurs mois nous avons
déjà engagé certaines de ces revues de
dépenses elles vont nous permettre de
dégager 2 milliards d'euros d'économie à
terme sur le dispositif Pinel sur le PTZ
et plusieurs centaines de millions
d'euros sur les politiques de l'emploi
enfin nous y parviendrons par les
économies supplémentair proposé par les
parlementaires les députés l'ont fait
les sénateurs sont évidemment les
bienvenus comme l'a fait le rapporteur
général pour proposer des économies
supplémentaires es auront toujours une
oreille attentive de ma part je salue de
ce point de vue là le travail qui a été
fait par la majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale et notamment par l'autre
excellent rapporteur général Jean-René
casenu qui a permis de dégager 1
milliard d'euros d'économie
supplémentaire par rapport à la copie du
gouvernement notamment grâce au gel des
allègements de charge entre 2,5 et 3,5
SMIC et la reconduction de la
contribution sur la rente inframarginale
je ne veux laisser aucun doute sur ce
sujet le temps des économies venu nous
tiendrons donc l'objectif de 4,4 % 2024
je m eng gage mais nous tiendrons aussi
notre objectif de revenir sous les 3 %
de déficit en 2027 nous le devons à nos
compatriotes nous le devons également à
nos partenaires européens nous devons
donc inscrire le sérieux budgétaire dans
la durée avec calme clarté et
détermination nous poursuivrons donc les
revues de dépenses et toutes les
dépenses publiques seront soumis à cette
évaluation et à cette revue nous
commencerons par cibler une dizaine de
secteurs d'ici la fin de l'année 2023
mais il y aura au total d'ici le
printemps 2024 trois revues de dépenses
une immédiate qui a déjà été annoncée
par la première ministre une deuxième en
début d'année et une troisème au début
du printemps de façon à examiner plus
d'une quarantaine de programmes de
dépenses publique et regardez là où
l'argent public est utile et efficace
dans ce cas-là il faut garder la dépense
là où en revanche l'argent public est
mal employé ne donne pas les résultats
attendus et dans ce cas-là il faut
baisser la dépense publicque c'est tout
simplement faire preuve de
responsabilité au-delà des revues de
dépenses publiques je confirme qu'il est
indispensable d'engager une réflexion
globale sur les missions de l'État sur
le périmètre de l'action publique sur
nos choix fondamentaux de politique
social sur l'enchevrettement des
compétences une mission été confiée au
député ERC sur ce sujet et nous aurons
l'occasion dans le cadre du Haut Conseil
des finances publiques locales
d'auditionner Eric vert sur ces
propositions pour simplifier la vie des
collectivités locales et simplifier la
vie d'autrre organisations de
gouvernance de manière plus globale ce
sera vous le voyez un des grands enjeux
de 2024 je rappelle notre stratégie de
réduction de la dépense sortir des
dispositifs exceptionnels liés au covid
c'est le premier temps engager les
revues de dépenses publiques c'est le
deuxième temps raison de trois revues de
dépenses entre maintenant et printemps
2024 et enfin en 3ème lieu interroger
plus globalement la structure de l'État
l'organisation administrative de la
France pour aller vers plus de
simplification et plus d'efficacité de
la dépense public pour établir les
comptes publics nous avons aussi besoin
d'une ligne de très grande clarté et de
très grande fermeté sur notre stratégie
économique et donc sur la croissance car
je le rappelle au bout du compte le plus
important pour réduire la dette et
accélérer le désendettement de la France
c'est d'avoir de la croissance qui
permet de créer des emplois et de la
richesse pour nos
compatriotes je refuse l'austérité
l'austérité n'a jamais permis de
rétablir les comptes publics en tout cas
pas de manière constructive je crois à
la responsabilité et au soutien à la
croissance et à l'activité nous
maintiendrons donc la politique de
l'offre qui a fait le succès de notre
politique économique qui qui a fait
l'attractivité de la France pour les
investissements étrangers depuis ces 7
dernières années grâce à cette politique
je le redis nous avons créé 2 millions
d'emplois dont 100000 emplois
industriels ouvert 300 usines relancé
des filières industrielles comme la
filière des batteries électriques et
fait de la France le pays le plus
attractif pour les investissements
étrangers en Europe cette détermination
à poursuivre la politique de l'ofre se
lit d'ailleurs dans ce budget 2024 avec
une baisse d'un milliard d'euros des
impôt de production qui doit nous amener
à supprimer la CVAE dans les meilleurs
délais possibles je constate donc que
dans le contexte budgétaire tendu que
nous connaissons la seule baisse d'impôt
majeur en 2024 est à destination des PME
du monde industriel et des entreprises
on ne peut exprimer je pense plus
clairement notre détermination à tenir
notre ligne de politique économique et
de politique de l'offre nous
renforcerons par ailleurs cette
politique de l'ofre dans les prochains
mois avec un effort massif de
simplification de la vie des entreprises
et j'en appelle à toutes les sénatrices
et tous les sénateurs toutes les
propositions de simplification de la vie
des entreprises en particulier des plus
petites d'entre elles seront les
bienvenus simplifier les règles
simplifier les normes simplifier les
contraintes pour permettre tout
simplement à nos entrepreneurs de se
concentrer sur la création de valeur et
la création d'emploi c'est une clé
absolue du succès de notre politique
économique nous devons en deuxè lieu
continuer à viser aussi dans les 3
années qui viennent le plein
emploi j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire à
plusieurs reprises mais je veux le
redire devant la représentation
nationale la France bute depuis 5
décennies un demi-siècle sur les 7 % de
taux de chômage quand ça va mal c'est 10
% de taux de chômage en France et quand
ça va bien c'est 7 et nous naviguons
entre ces 7 et 10 % de taux de chômage
sans jamais être parvenu depuis un
demi-siècle au plein emploi 5 % qui est
la règle pour d'autres grands pays
développés comme l'Allemagne ou comme
les États-Unis nous ne pouvons pas nous
satisfaire d'un plein emploi à 7 % le
plein emploi c'est 5 % c'est l'objectif
qui a été fixé par le président de la
République c'est l'objectif qui doit
être tenu mais puisque je veux vous
parler avec
franchise je redis que selon moi nous ne
parviendrons pas à 5 % de taux de
chômage à modèle social constant dans le
fond la gigantesque hypocrisie française
c'est que nous avons construit un modèle
social qui garantit un plein emploi à 7
% et certainement pas à 5 %. je souhaite
donc que nous nous donnions les moyens
tous ici collectivement d'atteindre
réellement le plein emploi c'est-à-dire
la garantie que chaque française chaque
Français quel que soit son âge quel que
soit son origine quelle que soit sa
formation puisse trouver facilement un
travail et ne s'inquiète pas pour son
avenir ou l'avenir de ses enfants pour
cela il faut ouvrir des chantiers et
poursuiv avec beaucoup de résolution
dans la voie de la transformation notre
modèle économique et social premier
chantier l'assurance chômage la première
des discriminations à
l'emploi c'est
l'âge quand vous avez plus de 55 ans on
vous ferme les portes cette
discrimination
elle est invisible
elle est tacite elle est sournoise mais
elle est
réelle avec toutes sortes de prétextes
et toutes sortes de contournements et
toutes sortes d'explications plus ou
moins fallacieuses à partir de 55 ans
une entreprise vous ferme les portes
vous dit que vous coûtez trop cher et
que vous feriez bien mieux de prendre
votre retraite voilà la réalité
inavouable du modèle social français et
voilà une réalité à laquelle je ne me
résignerai jamais car je considère
approchant moi-même de ces 55 ans que à
55 ans et loin au-delà on a des
compétences un savoir-faire une
expérience une histoire à faire partager
qui sont précieuses pour l'économie
française et précieuse pour les
entreprises mais il est évident qu'à
partir du moment où vous avez une durée
d'indemnisation du chômage qui est de 27
mois quand vous avez plus de 55 ans
alors qu'elle est de 18 mois pour les
autres compatriotes l'incitation
reprendre un emploi elle est assez
faible et que là aussi de manière
hypocrite et de manière déguisée on
transforme l'assurance chômage en
retraite je me refuse à continuer à
valider ce modèle car je considère qu'il
prive l'économie française de
compétences qui seraient précieuses pour
elle il faut donc modifier ces règles-là
je suis favorable à l'alignement de la
durée d'indemnisation chômage des plus
de 55 ans qui est de 27 mois sur celle
des autres chômeurs qui est de 18 mois
et je souhaite que les entreprises
assument toutes leurs responsabilités et
arrêtent d'expliquer aux seiors qu'il
coûtent trop cher et prennent leur
responsabilité pour faire toute leur
place au plus de 55 ans pour leur donner
la place qui leur revient quitte à ce
que au-delà de l'index senior on
travaille ensemble à d'autres
dispositifs qui permettrai d'inciter les
entreprises à garder les plus de 55 ans
dans l'entreprise et dans l'activité je
vous le dis avec beaucoup de force
beaucoup de gravité et beaucoup de
détermination car une société qui se
prive des compétences des plus de 55 ans
est une société hypocrite qui n'a pas
compris les évolutions attendues de tous
ceux qui ont de l'envie de la compétence
de l'énergie à faire valoir et à
partager le deuxième chantier c'est le
logement là aussi regardons les choses
en face et arrêtons avec l'hypocrisie de
notre modèle social qui refuse de voir
que beaucoup de jeunes ne peuvent pas
prendre un emploi aux Herbiers dans un
coin cher au président Bruno retaillot
alors même qu'il y a des emplois
disponibles et que les entreprises
affichent à leur rentrée qu'ell
recherchent désespérément des
compétences tout simplement parce que il
n'y a pas de logement disponible et
accessible pour des jeunes qui vrait
démarrer dans la vie et qu'il faudrait
travailler il faut donc construire plus
vite construire mieux construire plus
rapidement pour le logement et nous
avons besoin pour cela de mesures fortes
pour ce qui me concerne je suis prêt à
étudier monsieur le Président toutes les
propositions qui nous permettront de
construire plus rapidement en
particulier dans les zones tendues et je
considère que ce travail là passera par
une simplification massive et passera
aussi par un échange très approfondi
entre les maires et le gouvernement pour
voir à qui doit revenir la
responsabilité de cette construction et
des financements qui vont avec pour nous
assurer que ça aille plus vite je sais
Monsieur le Président rossot que vous et
votre groupe vous avez des idées je est
très heureux que nous puissions les
partager et si d'autres groupes le
souhaitent ils sont les bienvenus
aussi le troisième chantier au-delà du
logement et du modèle social et de
l'assurance chômage c'est celui de la
productivité arrêtons une fois encore de
nous mentir à nous-mêmees comme nous
nous mentons sur le modèle social sur
l'assurance chômage ou sur le logement
la productivité européenne est en berne
et c'est un drame économique
elle est en berne parce que l'Europe
n'innve pas assez elle est en berne
parce que l'Europe n'a pas encore créé
cette union des marchés de capitaux pour
laquelle je me bat depuis 5 ans qui nous
permettrait de lever les fonds
nécessaires pour innover plus vite et
pour innover davantage si nous ne créons
pas sous 3 ans l'Union des marchés de
capitaux il n'y aura pas d'intelligence
artificielle européenne elle sera
entièrement et totalement dans la main
des Américains et dans la main de
grandes entreprise privée américaine
pour gagner en productivité il faut
gagner en innovation pour gagner en
innovation il faut gagner en moyen de
financement c'est un chantier majeur sur
lequel je veux continuer à me battre
plus d'argent pour l'innovation et plus
d'innovation pour la productivité il
faut aussi que cette innovation soit
partagée par tous ouverte à tous quel
que soit l'origine quel que soit le
territoire quel que soit le lieu quel
que soit le sexe qu'on puisse avoir
accès à l'innovation comment notre
nation peut-elle se résigner avoir moins
d'ingénieurs femm aujourd'hui qu'elle
n'en avait il y a 20 ans comment est-ce
que nous pouvons traiter ce sujet pour
nous assurer que plus de jeunes femmes
s'engagent dans la carrière scientifique
plus de jeunes femmes deviennent
ingénieurs j'avais proposé qu'il y ait
des quotas dans les classes
préparatoires pour les jeunes femmes je
persiste et je signe s'il faut passer
par des quotas pour qu'il y ait plus de
jeunes femmes ingénieur passons par des
quotas mais nous ne résignons jamais à
n'avoir que 20 % d'une classe d'âge
ingénieur femmes parce que tout notre
système est organisé pour que ce soit
des hommes qui s'orientent vers les
sciences et vers les métiers d'ingénieur
c'est en travaillant sur cette
innovation pour tous quel que soit le
sexe quel que soit l'origine quel que
soit le territoire que la France
redeviendra une grande nation
d'innovation qu'elle gagnera en
productivité et qu'elle gagnera en
prospérité le 4è chantier c'est celui de
la réindustrialisation je redis notre
ambition redevenir une grande nation de
production la première économie
décarboné en Europe à horizon 2040
l'hypocrisie et des mensonges là aussi
on fait des ravages à force d'avoir
promis des lendemains qui chantent aux
Français en leur disant qu'on allait
faire une politique de production de
consommation uniquement pour la
consommation uniquement pour le
consommateur en redistribuant des
richesses qui n'avaient pas été créées
nous avons dans les décennies passées
appauvri la France c'est en redevenant
une nation de production avec des usines
avec des exploitations agricoles avec
des produits à forte valeur ajouté que
nous aurons des salariés mieux payés et
mieux formés est mieux qualifié plus de
prospérité à partager et un modèle
social qui tient il y a pas de modèle
social généreux possible sans production
de masse il n'y a pas de modèle social
qui tiennent à l'avenir si la France ne
redevient pas une grande nation de
production industrielle et agricole
c'est une priorité absolue là aussi nous
avons marqué des points et la politique
fiscale que nous avons mené
l'abaissement des impôts surz entreprise
la suppression de certains impôts de
production la simplification des
entreprises industrielles la loi
industrie verte le crédit d'impôt pour
la production de l'industrie doit nous
permettre de gagner cette bataille de la
production des usines des ouvriers des
ingénieurs qui nous permettront demain
de financer pas à crédit mais de
financer sainement notre modèle sociale
et la solidarité qui va avec pour cela
nous devons nous saisir de l'opportunité
historique qui est offerte par la
transition climatique la loi industrie V
qui a été adoptée largement notamment
ici doit nous permettre de parvenir à
cet objectif elle permettra notamment de
réduire les délais d'installation
d'usine de faciliter l'accès au fonciers
de mieux flécher les investissements
pour produire des éoliennes des panneaux
solaires des batteries électriques des
pompes à chaleur je rappelle que si nous
voulons gagner cette bataille de la
production cette bataille de la
relocalisation industrielle cette
bataille des usines il faut non
seulement investir massivement dans la
formation dans l'innovation et dans
l'ouverture de ces usines il faut aussi
nous doter des mêmes instruments de
protection que ceux dont dispose la
Chine et les États-Unis je suis
favorable à ce que nous livrions tous
ensemble la bataille pour le contenu
européen dans les règles européennes
nous devrions avoir des aides qui soient
réservé et fléché vers des projets qui
sont à contenu européens que ce soit à
60 ou 70 % quand on crée des batteries
solaires quand on ouvre des champs et au
lien offshore il devrait y avoir une
obligation de contenu européen ça se
pratique en Chine ça se pratique aux
États-Unis si nous respectons pas les
mêmes règles et si nous ne créons pas
cette règle du contenu européen il y a
fort à parier que le marché européen
deviendra un supermarché pour les
puissances étrangère mais qui ne nous
permettra pas de développer notre propre
capacité industrielle je suis favorable
à des règles de contenu européens dans
la législation européenne voilà les
quelques éléments que je voulais vous
présenter aujourd'hui mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs tout cela je le
redis suppose des comptes publics bien
tenus le retour à l'équilibre de nos
comptes et l'accélération du
désendettement c'est exactement ce à
quoi nous nous engageons avec le
ministre des comptes publques Thomas
casaznav merci à
tous merci Monsieur le Ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Thomas kaznav
ministre délégué chargé des comptes
publics pour 8
minutes monsieur le président monsieur
monsieur le ministre cher Bruno Le Maire
Monsieur le Président de la commission
des finances monsieur le rapporteur
général mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je dois tout d'abord vous dire
ma joie aujourd'hui d'avoir à mes côtés
un commissaire du gouvernement pour qui
c'est une première monsieur Santiago
forestier il partage nos travaux dans le
cadre de la 6e édition du programme duod
2023 notre combat Bruno Le Maire l'a dit
pour une société plus inquclusive passe
aussi par ses initiatives le duod a
permis en 2022 à près de 35000 personne
en situation de handicap d'amorcer un
parcours
d'insertion je suis heureux également
avec Bruno Le Maire de vous présenter ce
projet de loi de finan pour 2024 nous
avons récemment débattu de la loi de
programmation pluriannuelle pour nos
finances publiques hier vous avez voté
les conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire sur la loi de finances de fin
de gestion de l'année 2023 vous ne serez
pas surpris ce projet de loi de finances
pour 2024 s'inscrit dans la même
trajectoire et porte la même ambition
que les textes financiers que j'ai déjà
présentés et défendus devant vous notre
vision est cohérente et claire nous
souhaitons maîtriser nos finances
publiques nous souhaitons poursuivre
notre soutien à l'emploi et l'activité
nous souhaitons investir dans l'avenir
s'agissant de la maîtrise des finances
publiques tout d'abord ce projet de loi
de finance pour 2024 confirme la
trajectoire que nous avons inscrit dans
la loi de programmation en 2018 nous
avions réduit le déficit qui était
repassé sous la barre des 3 % cela nous
a permis permis de dégager les marges de
manœuvre nécessaires pour protéger
massivement les Français pendant la
crise sanitaire je tiens à le rappeler
nous avons protégé les emploi avec la
mise en place du chômage partiel nous
avons protégé les entreprises avec le
fond de solidarité nous avons protégé
les ménages les plus en difficultés avec
l'aide exceptionnelle de solidarité face
à l'inflation et l'augmentation des prix
de l'énergie l'État a pris en charge une
grande part des augmentations pour les
ménages les entreprises les
collectivités grâce au boucliers
tarifairire grâce à l'amortisseur au
dispositifs de soutien ciblé face à la
hausse des prix nous avons continué à
soutenir les Français avec la
revalorisation des prestations sociales
la prime exceptionnelle de rentrée ou la
remise carburant ces aides ont permis à
notre économie de tenir bon nous avons
un niveau de chômage historiquement bas
nous avons une croissance solide à 1 %
supérieur à la moyenne européennes les
entreprises ont continué de se
développer de produire nous sommes
également en train de gagner la bat
taille de l'inflation Bruno Le Maire y
est revenu grâce à ce choix de la
protection mais aussi et surtout grâce
aux réformes structurelles que nous
avons mené nous sommes en train de
sortir de ces crises mais cette
politique a eu un coût coût que nous
payons au prix fort avec l'augmentation
des taux d'intérêt qui alourdit la
charge de la dette il nous faut donc
acter la fin du qui qu'il en coûte sans
renoncer aux investissements et aux
politiques prioritaires c'est le sens de
ce projet de loi de finances pour 2024
la trajectoire que nous nous sommes
fixés établit un déficit public à 4,4 %
pour 2024 c'est une nouvelle étape
importante qui doit nous permettre de
repasser sous la barre des 3 % en 2027
nous réaliserons cet objectif car nous
ferons des économies les dépenses de
l'État baisseront en 2024 14 milliards
d'euros seront économisés grâce à la
sortie des dispositifs de crise 350
millions d'euros sur la politique de
l'emploi grâce à la réduction du chômage
500 millions d'euros en améliorant
l'efficience de la politique de
formation professionnel et de
l'apprentissage ces économies sont
ciblées effectuer un grand coup de rabot
comme je l'entends parfois dans les
dépenses de l'État aurait un effet
contre-productif sur notre croissance
j'en ai la conviction notre notre action
doit être précise et progressive nous
réaliserons cet objectif sans augmenter
les impôts c'est notre ligne directrice
depuis 2017 cette politique fonctionne
et nous permet d'atteindre les résultats
économiques que nous avons aujourd'hui
nous ne changerons pas de cap car il
produit des résult
pour l'année 2024 nous continuerons de
produire davantage nos prévisions
établissent un taux de croissance à 1,4
% certains prévisionnistes juger ce
chiffre optimiste aujourd'hui l'OCDE
comme la Commission européenne
confirment des prévisions entre 1,3 et
1,2 % de croissance certains nous
accusent aussi de faire porter l'effort
sur les collectivités cessons d'opposer
l'État et les collectivités
territoriales nous portons ensemble les
services publics je rappelle que les
concours financiers de l'État
s'élèveront à près de
5 milliards d'euros en 2024 la dotation
globale de fonctionnement augmentera à
nouveau de 220 millions d'euros après la
hausse de 2023 qui était la première en
13 ans les élus ont besoin pour investir
de visibilité et de clarté c'est la
raison pour laquelle le président de la
République a annoncé hier son intention
de réformer la dotation globale de
fonctionnement et saisi le CFL de cette
mission pour renforcer les capacités
d'investissement des collectivités nous
étendons le fond de compensation de la
TVA aux dépenses d'aménagement cela à
une demande des élus locaux et repr
représente un effort de 250 millions
d'euros nos collectivités bénéficieront
aussi de l'effort inédit en faveur de la
transition écologique le fond vert est
pérénisé à hauteur de 2,5 milliards
d'euros dont 500 millions d'euros pour
la rénovation des écoles comme annoncé
par le président de la République il
faut accélérer le verdissement de toutes
nos dépenses publiques état collectivité
opérateur et pour cela nous avons besoin
d'une boussole commune cette boussole
commune ce sont les budgets verts qui
seront généralisés dans les plus grandes
collectivités suite à nos débats à
l'Assemblée nationale je suis favorable
à cette avancée l'objectif de ces
budgets verts n'est pas de complexifier
la vie des élus c'est au contraire leur
permettre de valoriser la part de leur
budget qui est consacré à la transition
écologique la même logique doit
s'appliquer à la dette dont la part
verte doit être valorisée par les élus
ce budget est résolument tourné vers
l'avenir cela passe d'abord par la
traduction des lois de programmation qui
ont été adopté par le Parlement
concernant nos armées notre sécurité
notre justice le contexte international
nous rappelle à quel point il est
essentiel que nous disposions d'une
armée de premier endre à ce titre et
conformément à nos engagements le budget
de nos armées augmentera de 3,3
milliards d'euros dans le projet loi de
finance pour 2024 ces crédits
supplémentaires permettront d'assurer
l'aide de la France à l'Ukraine ils
permettront également de renforcer les
équipements le budget du ministère de
l'Intérieur augmentera aussi à hauteur
d'un milliard d'euros le recrutement
d'agents supplémentaires au service de
notre sécurité est essentiel nous
investirons également avec ce budget
dans l'amélioration de l'accueil des
victimes de violence conformément à la
loi de programmation du ministère de la
Justice nous augmentons le budget de 500
millions d'euros cette année cela doit
permettre en 2024 le recrutement de près
de 2000 fonctionnaires dont plus de 300
magistrats et plus de 300 greffiers afin
de garantir l'effectivité des peines
nous renforçons également les moyens de
l'administration pénitentiaire dans
laquelle près de 450 agents ser recruté
nous investissons massivement dans
l'éducation nationale il n'y a pas
d'investissement plus rentable que celui
de l'éducation de nos enfants la haosse
historique du budget de l'Éducation
nationale doit permettre de revaloriser
les professeurs conformément aux
engagements du gouvernement notre
investissement pour l'avenir consiste
enfin à investir massivement dans la
transition écologique nous avons de
dettes la dette financière bien sûr mais
également la dette écologique chaque
investissement que nous repoussons en la
matière hier nous coûtera plus cher
demain le projet de lois de finance pour
2024 consacre un investissement inédit
en faveur de la transition écologique
avec 10 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires pour la rénovation
thermique des logements et des bâtiments
publics pour décarboner nos transports
pour accompagner le nouveau modèle
agricole pour créer une industrie verte
et pour transformer notre modèle
énergétique ces dépenses vertes vont
aussi permettre d'accompagner les
ménages les Français ont besoin
d'investir dans la transition écologique
pour passer à l'électrique leur voiture
et pour isoler leur logement les aider
est un enjeu climatique mais aussi
économique et social sans cet
investissement supplémentaire nous ne
tiendrons pas nos objectifs climatiques
ce projet de loi de finance marque enfin
une étape décisive dans la lutte contre
la fraude la maîtrise et dépenses
publiques doit être un effort partagé
mais aussi un effort juste si nous
demandons des efforts pour maîtriser nos
comptes la contrepartie et de tout
mettre en œuvre pour lutter contre les
fraudes c'est un enjeu de cohésion
sociale c'est un enjeu de justice et de
consentement à l'impôt plusieurs mesures
contenues dans ce PLF nous permettront
d'être beaucoup plus efficaces dans la
lutte contre les fraudes je veux d'abord
mentionner le renforcement des moyens
humains avec 250 agents supplémentaires
dédiés à la lutte contre la fraude dès
l'année prochaine nous nous dotons des
moyens de nos ambitions nous renforcons
également l'arsenal législatif à
disposition des agents je voudrais
notamment citer la création d'une
sanction administrative générale pour
lutter contre tous les types de fraudes
aux aides publiques à l'Assemblée
nationale les débats ont permis
d'enrichir largement ce texte au total
ce sont 515 amendements qui ont été
repris issus de la majorité et des
oppositions nous avons repris plus
d'amendements que l'année précédente
derrière ce chiffre il y a une méthode
et un engagement celui du dialogue les
dialogues de Bercy d'abord ont permis de
partager nos points de vuees sur ce
budget nos divergences bien sûr mais
également les sujets de préoccupation
commun sur lesquels nous pouvons
travailler ensemble la première lecture
à l'Assemblée nationale a permis is
d'adopter des mesures très concrètes je
veux revenir sur quelquesunes d'entre
elles à l'initiative des députés nous
avons soutenu la prolongation de la
contribution sur les rentes
inframarginales sur l'année 2024 afin de
continuer de capter les profits
exceptionnels des énergéticiens afin de
donner plus de marge de manœuvre et
d'autonomie fiscale aux collectivités
nous avons soutenu la décorrélation de
la taxe d'habitation sur les résidence
secondaire et de la taxe foncière cette
mesure va dans le sens des nouvelles
relations
que nous souhaitons bâtir avec les
collectivités territoriales elle répond
à une attente de nombreux élus nous
avons également souhaité renforcer le
soutien de l'État aux collectivités
d'outrem au total les crédits de la
mission sont augmentés de 90 millions
d'euros supplémentairire parmi les
mesures adoptées nous avons soutenu une
aide exceptionnelle pour le financement
des infrastructures du quotidien ainsi
que des fonds dédiés à l'assistance
technique qui permettra de réaliser ses
projets pour la collectivité de Mayotte
nous avons retenu un fond dédié à l'eau
l'accès à une eau de qualité doit être
une garantie partout sur le territoire
c'est une priorité je vous rappelle
qu'hier soir nous avons adopté
définitivement le projet de loi de fin
de gestion qui contenait à l'initiative
du groupe RDPI 113 millions d'euros
supplémentaires à destination de la
collectivité de Mayotte concernant les
débats qui vont nous occuper au cours
des prochains jours c'est la même
méthode que je veux appliquerous som et
resterons je vais conclure monsieur le
président
resteront ouverts aux propositions
venues des sénateurs de tous les groupes
ce dialogue ne doit pas perdre de vue la
nécessité absolu de redresser nos
comptes publics nous ne renoncerons pas
la maîtrise de nos prélèvements
obligatoires j'ai confiance dans le
sérieux qui guide toujours vos travaux
et qui nous permettra d'aboutir j'en
suis certain à une version enrichie mais
équilibrée qui ne dégrade pas notre
trajectoire je vous remercie
merci parole est désormais à Monsieur
Jean-François Husson rapporteur général
de la commission des finances pour 15
[Applaudissements]
minutes monsieur le Président messieur
le ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission mes chers
collègues nous entamons aujourd'hui au
Sénat l'examen du PLF pour 2024
considéré comme adopté par l'Assemblée
nationale après avoir fait usage une
nouvelle fois de l'article 493 de notre
Constitution je vais formuler quelques
observations d'abord de méthode et parce
que c'est problématique à plusieurs
égards évidemment personne ne conteste
l'utilisation du 493 mais vous avez
choisi d'en faire usage à l'Assemblée
non pas pour clore une discussion
parlementaire en proposant une solution
de compromis non pas après avoir écouté
les uns et les autres et arbitrer entre
leurs propositions mais avant avant même
l'examen de tout amendement de la
première partie du PLF
2024 il faut noter qu'aucun amendement
de la première partie n'a été discuté en
séance publique à l'Assemblée nationale
et le débat sur la seconde partie a été
totalement tronqué on aurait pu croire
dans ces conditions que ce serait le
texte de 59 articles que vous aviez
déposé à l'Assemblée qui nous arit au
Sénat mais non pas du tout de
59 votre texte est passé à 234 articles
il a quadruplé de volume aucun débat à
l'Assemblée qure fois plus d'articles
c'est la grande inflation et ce sont
donc 175 articles nouveaux qui arrivent
au Sénat qui n'ont jamais été examinés
par le Conseil d'État qui n'ont fait
l'objet d'aucune étude d'impact pour
lesquels nous ne disposons d'aucune
évaluation préalable et qui n'ont même
pas été discuté en séance publicque à
l'Assemblée nationale vous ne pouvez pas
faire n'importe
quoir derrière le 493 l'organisation des
rencontres sous des formes dites les
dialogues de ber ne saurait remplacer le
débat parlementaire que vous évitez vous
organisez la démocratie à l'envers et je
le regrette et bien Messieurs les
ministre puisque vous êtes ici au Sénat
on vous propose de débattre ici pas 493
par contre je vous invite à bien vous
saisir des débats et de faire en sorte
qu'il en reste davantage que ça nétait
le cas l'an dernier venons-en maintenant
au budget de cette année qui arrive 2024
et bien monsieur le ministre j'ai repris
mes mes notes de l'an passé je pourrais
dire au mot près la même chose au même
endroit au même moment on a l'impression
que le temps s'est figé je disais par
exemple le budget de l'État présente des
niveaux de dépenses et de déficit que le
gouvernement ne parvient plus voire ne
cherche même plus à faire redescendre
des sommets qui qu'il avait atteint en
2020 je disais également des mesures
d'économie devraient être engagé dès
2023 je disais encore la trajectoire des
dépenses n'annonce ainsi aucune
inflexion pour les années à venir bis
repétita vous n'agissez pas est-ce par
manque de courage par manque d'audace
êtes-vous en P d'idée pas de solution
vous nous le direz peut-être nous
arrivons donc en 2024 et que s'est-il
passé rien les mêmes constats s'imposent
en 2024 le déficit public de atteindre
selon le gouvernement vos chiffres 4,4%
du PIB et encore j'y reviendrai
estimation optimiste puisque si la
croissance est plus faible que prévu
évidemment les recettes publiques le
seront aussi et si l'on retient les
prévisions par exemple du FMI la France
aurait en 2024 le deuxè déficit public
le plus élevé de la zone euro alors que
les autres pays profitent eux de la
sortie de crise pour se désendetter vous
continuez de laisser dériver la dette
ces mauvais résultats ce sont les vôtres
un endettement public qui se maintiendra
en 2024 un tau situé autour de 110 % du
PIB ce qui représente une hausse de près
de 12 points depuis 2017 là encore la
France devrait figurer désormais sur le
podium des pays les plus endettés de la
zone euro en 2024 derrière la Grèce et
l'Italie situation peu envable
reconnaissez-le et la France n'a pour
pas été soumis à des chocs économiques
plus violents que ses partenaires
européens puis alors ne nous faites pas
le coup des collectivités territoriales
qui serait responsable du
déficit on nous l'a souvent dit je
rappelle elles sont quasiment avec des
budgets en équilibre avec un léger
déficit de 0,3 points de PIB 15 fois
moins que le déficit de l'État donc vous
nous épargnerez les compliments et puis
le déficit budgétaire qui est prévu à un
niveau de 100
44,5 milliards d'euros en 2024 c'est
45,7 % des ressources netes sur le
périmètre du budget général et bien au
total vous savez que la France entre en
2024 malheureusement dans sa 50e année
consécutive de déficit budgétaire mais
je note que depuis 5 ans on a changé
d'air c'est celle des déficits extrêmes
un peu comme les périodes de Frid qui
paralyse l'économie autant que les
organismes la crise sanitaire semble
avoir établi un nouveau socle de déficit
de l'ordre de 150 milliards d'euros par
an le niveau était il y a 5 ans avant la
crise sanitaire de 90 milliards d'euros
et il nous préoccupa déjà à l'époque
alors vous n'arrêtez pas d'annoncer la
sortie du quoi qu'il en coûte autant
d'annonces sans lendemain qui
aboutissent malheureusement à
l'accumulation d'un surcroix déficit de
400 milli milliards d'euros en 5 ans
voilà malheureusement la réalité des
chiffres cette accumulation des déficits
elle a une une conséquence directe
lorsque n dispose pas de recette
exceptionnell c'est simple accroissement
de la dette accroissement de la charge
de la dette la charge de la dette elle
passerait en 2023 je reprends vos
chiffre de 48 milliards d'euros par an
en 2027 à 84 milliards d'euros à l'euro
près monsieur le ministre 60
%00 d'augmentation c'est un un
différentiel considérable et
particulrement préoccupant ce sont 36
milliards d'euros supplémentaires qu'il
nous faudra trouver en 2027 par rapport
à
2024 et dès 2026 les engagements
financiers seront et de loin le premier
poste de dépenses de l'État avec un
montant égal par exemple au budget
additionné des armées et des forces de
sécurité c'estd dire et bien dans ce
contexte comment trouver les ressources
pour faire face au défis à relever
comment financer la transition
écologique quand nos ressources sont à
ce point amputées par les
remboursement ce constat messieurs les
ministres la répétition de ce constat
depuis 5 ans témoigne de votre
impuissance
coupable de votre incapacité à AG et
vous avez beau multiplier les
déclarations optimistes comme autant de
paravant masquant vos faiblesse et
contredite par vos propres chiffres
messieurs les ministres je le dis vos
comptes ne sont pas tenus et c'est
mauvais pour la France alors vous
multipliez les bons mots j'ai entendu
encore tout à l'heure revue de dépenses
16 milliards d'économie prélèvement dans
la trésorerie des opérateurs
stabilisation de l'emploi public
poursuite du désendettement du pays vous
parlez beaucoup mais vous faites si peu
les les revu de dépenses n'ont accouché
à ce stade d'aucune économie dans le
prjat de finances vous ne cessez d'en
parler elles sont invisibles vous nous
annoncez 16 milliards d'économies on ne
les voit nulle part la seule chose qui
baisse ce sont les dépenses de crise la
crise est en passé elles disparaissent
par nature vous nous avez annoncé au
moins 1 milliard de prélèv sur les 2
milliards et demi de trésorerie
excédentaire des opérateurs où sont-ils
quels opérateurs vous n'avez là encore
pas su nous répondre vous avez annoncé
même fait adopter par le 493 dans votre
loi de programmation la stabilité des
emplois de l'État j'ai pris les chiffres
en 2024 les emplois vont progresser de
plus
8273 équivalent en plein dans le budget
2024 et je précise la masse salariale de
l'État à progr pr depuis 2017 de 10 % en
volume c'est aussi la réalité je vous le
redis le gouvernement monsieur messieurs
les ministres parle beaucoup mais vous
faites bien peu et bien je crains qu'à
vouloir ne pas regarder suffisamment la
vérité en face vous interdisiez de
trouver des problèmes au des solutions
pardon au problème de notre pays c'est
le cas par exemple et vous l'avez évoqué
mais on n pas le même diagnostic avec le
problème tique du logement secteur où
aujourd'hui tous les indicateurs sont
tout rouge et de manière ce qui est
grave structurelle chacun convient que
les dispositions du projet de loi de
finance que vous présentez ne sont pas à
la hauteur de la crise structurelle du
secteur qui est pourtant si important
décisif pour notre
économie alors vous avez vous appuyé sur
des prévisions économiques qui vous
aident d'une certaine manière et je le
disais il y a quelques instants vous voz
la face vous prévoyez une croissance en
2024 de plus 1 4 % quand le consensus
des économistes est plutôt à 0,8 c'est
quand même très très optimiste et
pourquoi pourquoi de notre part ce doute
concernant finalement vos préision vos
prévisions bah nous avons un peu regardé
vous semblez sous-estimer les les effets
de la politique monétaire je rappelle
que la Banque centrale européenne a
procédé en 14 mois à une augmentation de
450 points de base de ces taux d'
directeur ce qui est dans l'histoire le
durcissement le plus sévère dans ce
domaine or les effets de la politique
monétaire sont généralement produisent
des avec un effet retard de l'ordre
d'une année et bien le plein effet de
ces restrictions monétaires risque de se
faire sentir à la fin de l'année 2024
alors que vous feignez de croire qu'il
est majoritairement déjà derrière nous
je voudrait bien le souhaiter mais ça ne
me semble pas très crédible vous
anticipez également des d'emploi en 2024
quand d'autres à l'exemple de la Banque
de France qui n'est pas
suspecte comment dirais-je d'avoir des
prévisions par trop ni pessimiste ni
optimiste prévoit elle des destructions
de l'emploi et peut-être malheureusement
une remontée du chômage conjugué à la
hausse des taux cette remontée du
chômage rend de fait peu probable vos
hypothèses relatives à l'investissement
à la consommation des ménages même le
président du Haut Conseil des finances
publiques dans son audition au Sénat
dirait que la prévision gouvernementale
combinait des hypothèses toutes toutes
toutes favorables ça ne me paraît pas
tout à fait raisonnable d'ailleurs
monsieur le ministre de l'Économie j'ai
entendu les bémoles que vous aviez mis
par rapport notamment à la situation
instable au niveau international et bien
si ces hypothèses de croissance vous
aident finalement à embellir la réalité
les chiffres sont et restent têtus et
votre problème aujourd'hui votre
problème majur c'est la dépense la
dépense publique dont la dérive et
l'augmentation donne aujourd'hui le
vertige elle est à rebours de vos
discours parce que les dépenses de
l'État dans le budget 2024 vont
continuer d' augmenter hors mesure de
crise de près de 6 milliards d'euros je
le dis c'est irresponsable en 2024 la
plupart d'émissions du budget général
voilors crédit augmenté et pour SEP
d'entre elles isolément chacune plus
d'un
milliard je crois monsieur le ministre
que la Commission européenne a lancé un
signal d'alerte il y a quelques jours ça
ne nous honore pas et bien monsieur
messieur les ministre si vous voulez
retrouver les premières places je pense
qu'il va falloir faire beaucoup
d'efforts il va falloir travailler pour
renoncer pour redresser nos comptes
publics et bien travailler c'est aussi
ce que nous avons fait ici au Sénat avec
des
propositions nous ne nous sommes pas pas
contenter de déplorer une situation
inquiétante et puis de formuler des
critiques vous parlez de faire des
économies nous les faisons et nous
allons vous les proposer notre
commission des finances a voté plus de 5
milliards d'euros d'économie sur de
nombreuses politiques publiques
réduction des effectifs des opérateurs
meilleur ciblage de l'apprentissage fin
des
surbudgétisations qui font croire aux
gestionnaires publics que l'argent
public continue de cou à flot réforme de
l'aide médicale d'État réforme de
l'audiovisuel public révision du
bouclier électricité nous aurons
l'occasion d'IR revenir certaines de ces
pistes ne cessent d'être évoquées par la
majorité qui malheureusement laisse tout
en plan et bien nous nous vous proposons
d'agir cela fait aujourd'hui 3 ans que
vous parlez de la fin du coin qu'il en
coûte et en même temps vous proposez
encore à la représentation nationale
dans ce PLF une baisse d'impôt non ciblé
de 10 milliards d'euros sur les tarifs
de l'électricité qui est insoutenable
pour les finances publiques et
malheureusement indifférencier quel que
soit le revenu des ménages nous vous
proposons de cibler cette aide en
fonction des barevenenus et des classes
moyenne vous parlez de bien gérer
l'argent public et en même temps vous
proposez dans votre texte écoutez bien
d'exonérer les fédérations sportives
olympiques de tous les impôts y compris
pour les salariés sur les revenus qu'ils
perçoivent pendant 5 ans mais comment
pouvez-vous parler aujourd'hui de bonne
gestion de l'argent public et assurer
une telle mesure devant les
Français nous proposerons de la
supprimer et au regard des quelques
échanges que nous avons eu en commission
je crains que vous ayez les oreilles qui
sifflent le président de la
République annonce qu'il financera le
Centre national de la musique mais en
même temps et enfin le gouvernement ne
fait rien et ne propose rien et bien
nous proposons un financement et un
avenir messieurs les ministres il est
passé 15h je vous le dis l'heure du
réveil a sonné le quoi qu'il en coûte
vous a anesthésié il constitue
aujourd'hui un fardeau dont vous
n'arrivez pas à vous défaire et bien ce
qu' l' en coûte en réalité c'est votre
incapacité à tenir certaines de vos
promesses comme la CVAE que vous
n'arrivez plus à faire
disparaître
le quoi qu'il en coûte c'est
malheureusement la mise en cause de
votre crédibilité politique qui fait
craindre aux ménages et aux chefs
d'entreprise des hausses d'impôts
prochaines et malheureusement presque
déjà en filigrane mes chers collègues je
vais donc vous proposer de suivre l'avis
et les votes faits par la commission des
finances pour permettre un redressement
de notre pays pour redresser les comptes
publics parce que la France et les
Français en ont grand besoin je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur général la
parole est à présent à Monsieur Claude
renal président de la commission des
finances pour 10
minutes monsieur le Président messieurs
les ministres monieur le rapporteur
général chers collègues nous députons
donc aujourd'hui l'examen en séance du
projet de loi de finances pour
2024 en ma qualité de président de la
commission des finances je rappellerai
que cela fait plus d'un mois déjà que le
rapporteur général et l'ensemble des
rapporteurs spéciaux procèd à l'analyse
de ce nouveau budget tant dans sa partie
recette que dépenses je remercie
d'ailleurs l'ensemble des membres de la
commission pour leurs travaux riches et
approfondis qui ont permis de poser des
constats de faire des propositions et
d'établir des avis sur l'ensemble des é
missission budget annexe et comptes
spéciaux qui composent le budget de
l'État au cours de 37 he de commission
passé ensemble depuis début octobre nous
avons ainsi que les commissions pour
avis et leurs rapporteurs que je salue
conduit un nombre considérable
d'auditions et avons désormais alors que
s'ouvre l'examen en séance publique une
vision plutôt clair de ce que nous
inspire votre projet de loi de finances
messieurs les ministres comme l'an
dernier notre examen intervient après
une séquence un peu particulière
puisque'avec l'utilisation du 493 à
l'Assemblée nationale très peu de
dispositions du PLF ont été débattu la
première ministre a même déclenché la
procédure avant l'examen du premier
article de première partie cela ne vous
a pas pourtant empêché voir cela a
peut-être d'ailleurs facilité le fait
que vous insériez 115 articles
additionnels en première partie puis 60
en seconde partie partie le texte est
ainsi passé cela a été dit de 60 à 235
articles à l'Assemblée nationale c'est
quatre fois plus nous aurons l'occasion
de revenir sur chacun des dispositifs et
de les discuter je vais si vous le
permettez utiliser le temps dont je
dispose dans cette discussion générale
pour développer certaines idées qui me
tiennent à cœur et qui je crois mérite
d'être
rappelé une fois n'est pas coutume je
parlerai d'abord de dépenses publiques
en effet la dépense publique monsieur le
rapporteur général n'est pas un gros mot
et j'aimerais combattre ici certaines
facilités un peu lassantes comme celle
qui consiste à systématiquement retenir
l'indicateur de la dépense publique
exprimé par rapport au Produits
Intérieurs
brut après 61 ,4 % du PIB en 2020 en
raison de la crise sanitaire la dépense
publique représenterait
55,8 % du PIB en 23 et
55,4 en
2024 ainsi exprimé la dépense publique
paraît donc très élevée et la diminution
de cet agrégat est systématiquement
interprété comme une bonne
nouvelle comme vous le dites monsieur le
ministre vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
ne soyons pas hypocrite cela vaut pour
tous je veux rappeler que ces chiffres
ne signifient en aucun cas que le public
capterait 55 % du produit intérieur brut
ce qu'on nous explique sans arrêt car
dans cet indicateur des éléments
constituent effectivement des part du
PIB comme la consommation et
l'investissement public mais pas
d'autres par exemple tous les transferts
sociaux non rien à voir avec ça prendre
le PIB qui est une somme de valeur
ajoutée comme point de comparaison avec
des montants qui n'ont rien à voir avec
des valeurs ajoutées c'est introduire la
plus grande confusion dans les esprits
ainsi si l'on créa un indicateur
similaire pour les dépenses privées
elles atteindraient plus de 200 % du PIB
le haut niveau de cet indicateur très
imparfait dit simplement quoi bah que
nous avons collectivement fait le choix
depuis longtemps de socialiser une
grande partie des dépenses des
ménages ce n'est pas par par exemple le
choix fait par les États-Unis on peut se
comparer leurs dépenses publiques
représentent l'équivalent de 45 % du PIB
mais leurs dépenses de santé pour
l'essentiel vous le savez sont privé et
donc ne sont pas incluses dans cet
indicateur alors que qu'elle représente
18 % du PIB contre 12 % en France
autrement dit si l'on dessocialiser les
dépenses de santé on rejoindrait donc le
niveau américain mais je ne crois pas
que ni les uns ni les autres nous
souhaitions faire cela si le son se
compare à l'Allemagne dont le niveau de
dépenses publique approche les 50 % du
PIB on constate aussi que l'écart tient
essentiellement à des dépenses plus
élevé en France pour la protection
sociale 34 points de PIB en 2021 par
exemple contre
29,5 %. au total la France est une
économie de marché où la puissance
publique assume une redistribution
élargie qui permet de fortement
resserrer les écarts de revenus entre
ménages pauvres et aisé et c'est un
rapport nous rappelle une récente note
de l'INC un un rapport de 18 ramené à 3
par cette politique générale de
redistribution c'est d'ailleurs je le
dis comme cela c'est ce qui tient notre
société française aujourd'hui c'est bien
cela alors certains le déplore pour ma
part je m'en réjouis il me paraît
essentiel de préserver ce système tout
en essayant bien sûr de toujours faire
mieux dire cela
ne signifie pas que je méconnaisse la
nécessité d'assurer un meilleur
équilibre de nos finances publiques la
charge de la dette progresse sous
l'effet notamment de la haute des tau
personne ne peut le nier encore moins
s'en réjouir et c'est là Monsieur les
ministres que je ne comprends toujours
pas votre
entêtement à réduire les recettes de
l'État en période de crise tous le FMI
le haut Commissar au finances publi la
Cour des comptes la Banque de France
vous disent depuis longtemps que l'heure
n'est pas la réduction des prélèvements
obligatoires si j'étais comme vous
convaincu de la nécessité de réduire
l'impôt sur les sociétés lorsqu'il est
passé de 33 % à 25 %. je ne vous suis
plus depuis longtemps maintenant vous le
savez c'est-à-dire que depuis que vous
avez au fil des années supprimé l'impôt
sur la fortune mais aussi la taxe
d'habitation y compris pour les plus
riches la contribution sur la valeur à
ter des entreprises et même la
contribution à l'audiovisuel publicque
une cinquantaine de milliards annuels se
sont évaporés depuis 2017 ce ces
milliards que précisément aujourd'hui
vous rechercher désespérément pour
amamener en 2027 notre déficit en
dessous des 3 % du PIB en 2018 monsieur
les ministres et surtout monsieur le
ministre le mer qui était là grâce à la
politique de vos
prédécesseurs la France quitté la
procédure de déficit excessif je vous
rappelle qu'en 2017 on vous a laissé le
pays avec 3 % de déficit et donc l'année
suivante vous avez pu effectivement
quitter la procédure de déficit excessif
mais malheureusement vous êtes en train
de nous y ramener en 2024 si on en croit
les services de la Commission c'est
vraiment une belle réussite et tout ça
pour quel résultat une augmentation de
l'épagne des ménages les plus aisés ça
c'est sûr et cette épargne aujourd'hui
vous aimeriez la voir en fait revenir
ressortir des comptes d'épargne et
revenir sous forme de
consommation et puis d'autre part une
augmentation des résultats des
entreprises qui malheureusement ces
résultats sont plus tournés ces
entreprises sont plus tourné vers le
rachat d'action
que vers l'investissement productif
n'aurait-il pas été plus utile que
l'État conserve ses moyens pour soutenir
comme vous l'avez d'ailleurs très bien
fait durant la pandémie les Français et
les entreprises mais plutôt en limitant
l'appel à l'endettement parce que vous
aviez quelques ressources permettant de
le faire naturellement et bien j'ai peur
que la réponse à cette question soit
directement dans la question
cette année le projet de loi de finance
pour 2024 est à peu près en ligne avec
la loi de programmation et le programme
de stabilité en
2025 nous le savons tous vous l'avez dit
l'exercice sera bien plus compliqué
quasiment plus de relica du plan de
relance à utiliser une revue des
dépenses au résultat pour l'instant plus
que décevant je rappelle qu'il y avait
un groupe de députés qui s'était chargé
de trouver des solutions on n'est pas
arrivé à un milliard d'euros d'économie
on s'en souvient tous j'ai donc bien
peur que tout simplement et malgré vos
dire le sujet recette nouvelle ne
s'impose rapidement aussi bien
d'ailleurs que la remise en cause des
nombreuses lois de programmation que
votre gouvernement nous a proposé car en
ayant des lois de programmation qui
augmentent la dépense je vois pas bien
comment on va résoudre l'équation le
retour sur Terre monsieur le ministre ne
fait que commencer alors j'ai un petit
conseil amical pour conclure attachez
bien vos ceintures merci merci monsieur
le
Président mes chers collègues nous
passons à la discussion de la motion
tendant à opposer la question
préalable messieur Éric Boquet Pascal
Savoldelli et les membres du groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste kanaki ont déposé une motion
distribuée sous le numéro
1666 tendant à opposer la question
préalable au texte en discussion la
parole est à monsieur Éric Boquet pour
la motion pour 10
minutes monsieur le Président messieurs
les ministres mes chers
collègues nous voilà donc engagé dans le
débat budgétaire pour l'année
2024 nous allons donc dans les semaines
qui viennent parler énormément de
chiffres cela paraît tout à fait logique
mais nous faisons le choix messieurs les
ministres de consacrer ce temps de
parole à la vie des gens au quotidien de
nos concitoyens et des concitoyens à qui
ce budget devrait apporter des réponses
concrètes et
efficaces le mardi 14 novembre dernier
le Secours Catholique a publier son
rapport annuel sur l'état de la pauvreté
en France édition
2023 les données sont absolument
saisissantes après la crise du covid
plus de 550000 personnes ont basculé
dans la pauvreté et depuis évidemment
l'inflation galopante sur les prix des
denrées alimentaires par exemple a
encore aggravé la
situation le taux de pauvreté atteint
désormais 14,5 % en progression de
progression de 09 points mais je vous le
disais nous souhaitons évoquer à cet
instant des propos le cas cronqué le
concret de Chantal une histoire relatée
dans un article du journal Le Monde daté
du Jeudi 16 novembre dernier Chantal à
60 ans raconte son existence elle fait
partie des millions de personnes aidées
chaque jour par les bénévoles du Secours
Catholique du Secours populaire des
banques alimentaires des Restos du cœur
ou encore des épiceries solidaires
l'idée n'est pas bien évidemment de
sombrer ni dans le populisme ni dans la
démagogie il s'agit de rendre compte de
la réalité quotidienne de de nos
concitoyennes et concitoyens quand
chantal a payé ses frais fixes il lui
reste 17 € par jour pour vivre elle ne
se plaint pas je me dis toujours qu'il y
a pire que moi nous dit-elle comme 95 %
des personnes aidées par le score
catholique elle se situe elle se situe
en dessous du seuil de pauvreté fixée à
60 % du revenu médian soit environ 1210
€ par mois chantal a eu un parcours de
vie un peu chaotique séparation d'avec
son mari puis atteinte d'un cancer du
sein après un licenciement et plusieurs
années d'incapacité elle a pu rejoindre
un emploi à condition de faire peu
d'heure elle s'accorde 15 jours de congé
par an ce qui signifie perdre une partie
de ces 1200 € mensuels obtenu en
cumulant pension d'invalidité salaire
indemnité au titre de son assurance
prévoyance plus l'aide au logement
Chantal dont le nom a été modifié pour
les besoins de l'article reconnaît
effectuer quelques heur de travail au
black
parce que si je déclarais ma pension
diminuait son avenir l'inquiète aussi si
elle prend sa retraite à 62 ans elle ne
dépassera pas 826 € par mois tant que je
peux je travaille chaque sortie chaque
rentrée d'argent sont notés dans un
carnet mais entrons dans le détail des
chiffres d'une vie précaire Chantal doit
assumer 682 € de frais fixes chaque mois
242 € de loyer pour son logement social
une fois déduite l'a personnalisée au
logement 109 € d'électricité 77 € de
mutuel 52 € d'assurance voiture 30 €
d'Internet il lui reste donc bien 17 €
par jour pour assumer toutes les autres
dépenses elle attend les promotions elle
fait durer ses six ses 10 t cachés
surgelés tout le mois elle a renoncé aux
poissons et aux fruits avec les quelques
dizaines d'euros gagnés au noir ell
s'offre du tabac à rouler et des parties
de l'auto le dimanche on s'étonne
parfois mes chers collègues de la
fréquentation en hausse des lotau
organisés par les associations dans nos
communes elle continue de verser les 21
€ mensuels de son assurance décès comme
ça mes enfants ne paieront pas dit-elle
en revanche elle n'a pas les moyens de
se payer un dentier alors que les 13
dents une conséquence de sa
chimiothérapie qui lui reste LA FONT
atrocement souffrir elle se bourre de
doliitpran bien au-delà des doses
autorisées mais chantal est résiliente
et force l'admiration
je ne suis pas à plaindre quand même
j'ai un toit et je suis bien entouré il
y a quelques temps sa voiturette sans
permis est tombée en panne l'association
l'a aidé à payer les réparations
d'autant qu'elle a perdu de semaines de
salaire faute de pouvoir se rendre chez
son employeur Chantal sait qu'elle n'a
pas droit à l'erreur une fois j'ai fait
ma déclaration pour la pension
d'invalidité 2 jours trop tard je n'ai
rien touché pendant 3 mois aujourd'hui
chantal a rejoint les bénévoles de la
permanence alimentaire je veux ici
saluer la journaliste du Monde qui a
écrit ce récit madame Claire anné cette
histoire singulière nous ramène
forcément à d'autres cas multiples que
nous avons tous en tête et elle illustre
parfaitement ce que signifie dans notre
société une vie précaire le Pacte des
solidarités présenté par le gouvernement
a fait réagir les associ association de
lutte contre la pauvreté elle dénonce un
manque d'ambition et aucune mesure forte
pour lutter efficacement contre la
pauvreté seulement un catalogue de
mesures dont beaucoup étaient déjà
connus avec une petite rallonge
pour couvrir les besoins des
associations alimentaires malgré ce
contexte de difficulté aggravé pour une
très grande partie de la population vous
confirmez votre volonté de réduire la
dépense publique à tout prix et vos
choix dogmatiques de refus d'agir sur la
fiscalité des plus aisés de notre pays
et des dividendes qui explosent
réduisent du même coup les capacités de
l'État à agir afin de répondre aux
grands défis de notre temps à l'autre
pôle de notre société le paysage est
très diff différent quand notre témoin
Chantal totalis 682 € de frais fixes par
mois l'homme le plus riche du monde
notre compatriote Bernard Arnaud
consomme 657 l de gasoil par heure avec
son mégaot fort heureusement taxé avec
une TVA 0% grâce au contrat de transport
internationaux votre prédécesseur
monsieur le ministre répétait à l'envie
que la France n'était pas un paradis
fiscal pour les plus riches même le
magazine challenge l'été dernier
conteste cette affirmation dans son
numéro de juillet
établissement le classement des 500
premières fortunes professionnelles de
France pour la quasittalité de la
population le système fiscal français
est progressif avec un taux d'imposition
qui augmente avec les revenus en
revanche pour le sommet de la pyramide à
partir des 01 % les plus riches il
devient dégressif chutant à 26 % pour
les
0,0002 % des plus fortunés soit 75
milliardaires identifiés ces derniers
perçoivent les entiel leur revenu à
travers les profits de leurs entreprises
taxé à un taux plus faible que celui de
l'impôt sur le revenu s'ils avaient été
taxé au taux de l'impôt sur le revenu
ces 75 milliardaires auraient payé un
taux d'impôt à 59 %. monsieur
jean-pisani ferry l'inspirateur du
programme économique du candidat
Emmanuel Macron en 2017 prône la
taxation du patrimoine des plus aisés
afin de financer notamment la lutte
contre le changement climatique Monsieur
Bruno Le Maire ici présent semble enfin
avoir compris ce que sont les super
profits nous l'encourageons à poursuivre
sa progression en décidant de les taxer
enfin à la bonne hauteur monsieur le
ministre cette question préalable c'est
aussi un appel à mener un débat résolu
et déterminé dans la recherche de
recettes nouvelles vous ne vous
intéressé qu'aux économies dans la
dépenses publiqu deux rapports récents
soulignent une volonté politique
insuffisante dans la lutte contre
l'évasion fiscale celui de l'Assemblée
nationale qui revient notamment sur les
moyens humains nécessaires vous en avez
parlé monsieur le ministre casna na et
souigne les 2500 emplois supprimés dans
le contrôle fiscal entre 2013 et 2021
demandez aussi des comptes à nos
partenaires européens je pense au
Luxembourg qui éberge 55000 sociétés
offshore ou encore à Chypre qui
accueille volontiers au sein de l'Union
européenne l'argent sal des oligarques
russes avantages fiscaux tolérances
judiciaire ou encore visa dorés un
second rapport émanant celui-là de la
Cour des comptes celle-ci s'interroge
sur l'efficacité de l'action de plus en
plus important de l'intelligence
artificielle ce rapport livre également
une charge contre entre contre les
indicateurs censés mesurer l'efficacité
du contrôle fiscal mais qui ont je cite
l'inconvénient de ne pas faire le lien
entre modalité de ciblage motif de
programmation et résultats messieurs les
ministres en matière de lutte contre
l'évasion fiscale il est grand temps de
chausser les bottes de se lieux sur le
champ des recettes je citerai à nouveau
la Cour des comptes qui a rendu un
rapport fort intéressant en juillet
dernier sur le pilotage et l'évaluation
des dépenses fiscales plus communément
connues s le nom de niche fiscale il
existe dans notre pays pas moins de 465
dispositifs fiscaux visant à réduire
l'impôt leur coût total dépasse les 94
milliards d'euros la Cour des comptes
indique que leur concentration sur
l'impôt sur le revenu l'impôt sur le
société et la TVA 90 % du montant des
dépenses fiscales affecte fortement le
rendement de ces derniers contribue à
l'érosion des basses c et fragilise la
trajectoire de consolidation des
finances publiques en conclusion la Cour
indique les programmes d'évaluation
fixés par les dernières lois de
programmation des finances publiques
n'ont pas été respectées ainsi aucune
évaluation sur les 11 prévus dans le
programme de travail pour 2002 n'a été
réalisé certains dispositifs y compris à
fort enjeu n en outre pas fait l'objet
d'évaluation depuis 10 ans je pense que
l'on pourrait inscrire dans ceci le
pacte du tril certaines niches ont sans
nul doute leur utilité pour d'autres il
y aurait matière investigation messieurs
les ministres quelle suite le
Gouvernement entend-il donner à ce
rapport riche en recette nouvelles cette
question préalable c'est le surgissement
de l'état réel de notre société dans nos
débats c'est aussi un appel à explorer
des pistes nouvelles en termees de
recettes fiscales nouvelles qui pourrai
nous éviter un recours massif à
l'aggravation de la dette publique ce
PLF 2024 selon les mots de Monsieur le
Maire doit dégager 16 milliards d'euros
d'économie afin je cite de permettre à
la France d'entamer le processus de
désendettement DIC cite le ministre
monsieur le ministre qui peut
sérieusement croire à cette fable quand
vous avez d'ors et déjà décidé
d'emprunter 285 milliards d'euros l'an
prochain quand le total de notre dette a
dépassé les 3000 milliards non
décidément ce budget ne s'attaque pas
radicalement au grands mots de notre
société je vous remercie merci chers
collègues je vais demander l'avis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
général l'avis est défavorable je je
veux donner de deux ou trois mot
d'explication d'abord j'ai envie de dire
que les les 10 minutes dont peut-être
une bonne moitié a été l'occasion de
nous
narrer la vraie vie d'un CRE de
concitoyens vous avez d'ailleurs la
courtoisie et je pense que le propos
était juste de se dire et de nous dire
que autour de nous chacun pourrait
utiliser des comparaisons semblable et
puis dans votre deuxème partie vous avez
redonné également de la perspective donc
ça honore le débat mais je me dis
heureusement que le Sénat choisit de
débattre je le redis je l'avais dit en
introduction du propos si on choisissait
de donner suite à votre initiative le
débat serait clos il n'y aurait eu aucun
débat au Parlement je crois que notre
démocratie ne peut pas se permettre
cette prise de risque mais j'en profite
pour redire au ministres au
pluriel que nous serons attentifs parce
qu'on on est comme tout le monde he ici
on aime travailler on le fait
sérieusement nous allons partagera
évidemment pas tout mais ça c'est le
propre de la société en général et débat
public mais je je vous demande vraiment
d'être attentif et de faire en sorte de
retenir bien davantage d'éléments et de
propositions que l'expérience qui a été
la nôtre l'année dernière parce que
sinon vous la démocratie sortira
affaiblie et nous perdant perdant un
pouvoir national exécutif affaibli un
Parlement dont les voix ne serait pas
entendu et prise en compte on peut pas
se permettre ce risque là donc et pour
cette raison je je le redit un avis
défavorable sur la proposition du groupe
communiste merci monsieur le rapporteur
général avis du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre même avis monsieur le
Président merci y a-t-il des
explications de vote monsieur
Savoldelli merci merci monsieur le
Président messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues très très très
rapidement évidemment moi je comprends
l'argument du du du rapporteur général
sur si on votait cette question prable
il y a aucun
débat mais pourquoi a mis cette question
préalable quel
débat on va commencer un débat où on a
un niveau d'emprunt record
285 milliards un déficit de 145
milliards on
l'accepte on va débattre d'un projet de
loi quand même je sais qu'ici nous on a
l'habitude de respecter nous nos
collègues de l'Assemblée nationale un
projet de loi où il y a eu 175 articles
d'ajoutés c'est le rapporteur général
qui l'a dit tout à l'heure et il avait
raison au nom du 493 donc pourquoi on
fait cette question préalable parce que
quoi qu'on va décider
ici le retour à l'Assemblée nationale
c'est le même dispositif qui va être mis
en place celui qui a fait qu'à
175 articles ajoutés sans le débat de
nos collègues à l'Assemblée nationale et
qui vont être arbitrés avec un 493 à la
fin donc voilà c'est c'est c'est pas
qu'une humeur ou une sorte de de
l'opposition pour s'opposer c'est voilà
les les les dés sont
pipés et et c'était bien de faire appel
au nos précédent débat de projet de loi
de finance
ou à la fin quand même il y a usurpation
sur la qualité des débats et y compris
d'amendements votés voilà c'est le sens
de cette question préalable nous ici on
n pas le on n pas la censure on n pas
d'autres dispositions c'est le Sénat
c'est pas l'Assemblée nationale donc je
pense que c'est bien aussi de de
signifier qu'il y a un coup d'arrêt
quand même voilà c'est ce qu'on a voulu
faire dans le cadre de des dispositions
qui nous sont offertes à nous qui est
celle de la question préalable merci de
votre attention merci chers collègues je
vais consulter le Sénat sur la motion
tendante à opposer la question préalable
je rappelle que l'adoption de cette
motion entraînerait le rejet du texte en
discussion en application de l'article
59 du règlement le scrutin public
ordinaire et de droit le scrutin
sera ouvert dans quelques instants le
scrutin est
ouvert
personne ne demande à voter le scrutin
est
clos résultat de ce tin votant 344
exprimé
260 pour cette motion 18 contre la
motion 242 la motion n'est pas adoptée
elle est
rejetée dans la suite de la discussion
générale la parole est à Monsieur Didier
rambau pour le groupe RDPI pour 6
minutes merci
monsieur le Président messieurs les
ministres monsieur le Président de la
Commission monsieur le rapporteur
général mes chers collègues les Jeux
Olympiques et les Jeux paralympiques ont
leurs épreuves de Marathon ici au Sénat
nous avons le nôtre le marathon
budgétaire et cette année les sentiers
s'annoncent escarpés et le parcours
quelque peu rallongé dans un contexte
d'inflation pas uniquement législative
où la prévision de croissance sélève à
1,4 % les recettes de l'État pourrai
connaître une hausse de 14 millions
d'euros par rapport à 2023 cela témoigne
d'un certain dynamisme et d'une bonne
résistance de l'économie française face
aux crises ce n'est pas le fruit du
hasard mais bien la conséquence de
décisions politiques menées depuis plus
de 5 ans ce dynamisme se poursuivra en
2024 avec une économie en essort
l'imposition minimale à l'impôt sur les
sociétés permettra de rapporter 1,5
milliard d'euros par an à partir de 2026
et de limiter la concurrence fiscale
internationale c'est une victoire
décisive pour la réindustrialisation de
la France grâce à l'engagement du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre vous
l'avez rappelé ce matin sur une radio ce
budget représente la fin d'une époque
celle du quoi qu'il en coûte s'il marque
indéiablement une étape décisive dans la
réduction du déficit il n'en or pas
moins que les dépenses de ce budget en
fond un budget résolument engagé engagé
pour le financement des services publics
prioritaire engagé pour la transition
écologique et surtout engagé pour nos
collectivités nous constatons tous nos
concitoyens ont des attentes fortes en
matière de service public ce budget
c'est 3,3 milliards d'euros de plus pour
l'armée une augmentation de 5 % du
budget de la justice et un recrutement
de 6700 agents publics supplémentaires
dont 3000 pour accompagner les élèves en
situation de handicap 1900 dans les
tribunaux et 2600 dans la police mais le
budget pour 2024 c'est surtout 3,9
milliards d'euros supplémentaires à
destination d'un secteur qui me tient à
cœur en tant que fils d'instituteur
l'éducation nationale face à de
multiples difficultés à commencé par
l'enjeu d'attractivité du métier
d'enseignant ce projet loi de finance
permet de concrétiser la revalorisation
historique de leur rémunération opéré
dès la rentrée scolaire 2023 un effort
inédit et sans conditions qui se traduit
par 100 € nets mensuel pour tous les
enseignants une rémunération minimale de
2100 € en début de carrière sans oublier
la réforme du lycée professionnel ou
encore la hausse de la valeur du point
d'indice de la fonction publique décidée
par le gouvernement en juillet dernier
dont les effets se feront ressentir en
2024 2024 marquera donc une hausse
historique de 3,9 milliards d'euros soit
une augmentation de 6,5 % par rapport à
202 23 au service de la jeunesse de
notre pays mes chers collègues Antoine
de saintuxuri l'écrivait avec sa
lipidité singulière nous n'héritons pas
de la terre de nos ancêtres nous
l'emprunons à nos enfants par conséquent
face à l'urgence du dérèglement
climatique notre pays doit montrer
l'exemple en en agissant davantage cela
nécessite des moyens financiers
supplémentaires en cohérence avec le
rapport pisaniféie qui estime les
besoins d'investissement à hauteur de 60
milliards d'euros d'ici 2030 le
gouvernement prend sa part avec un
effort inédit de 7 milliards d'euros de
crédit supplémentaires consacrés à la
planification écologique rien qu'en 2024
alors quels seront les projets concernés
la rénovation des logements et des
bâtiments de l'état des investissement
dans le réseau ferroviaire le
développement de ha les moyens déédiés
au renouvellement forestier le fond vert
avec une partie consacrée au recyclage
des friches voilà voici quelques
exemples parmi tant d'autres qui seront
financés grâce à ce budget sans oublier
bien évidemment l'une des mesures
fiscales les plus importantes de la
première partie de ce PLF la création du
crédit d'impôt d'industrie verte un
outil attendu depuis l'examen de la loi
relative à l'industrie verte qui devrait
permettre de générer environ 23
milliards d'euros d'investissement et de
créer plus de 40000 emplois directs sur
le territoire national d'ici 2030 la
planification écologique est en cours
affirmer que rien n'est fait en ce sens
c'est dans le meilleur des cas de la Mau
maaise fois dans le pire un dénis de
réalité inquiétant dans notre
institution bien souvent surnommé la la
chambre des territoires alors que le
Congrès des Maires touche à Saint fin un
mot sur la situation financière des
collectivités territoriales si ce si ce
budget caractise la fin du quoi qu'il en
coûte c'est cependant tout sauf la fin
de l'accompagnement de nos collectivité
après avoir connu en 2023 sa première
hausse depuis 12 ans la dotation global
de fonctionnement augmentera à nouveau
de 220 millions d'euros le fond de
compensation pour la TVA fait l'objet
d'un élergissement aux dépenses
d'aménagement une demande forte des élus
locaux à laquelle le gouvernement répond
favorablement un effort supplémentaire
bienvenu de 250 millions d'euros enfin
mes chers collègues la France doit avoir
un budget mais le Sénat peut l'affiner
c'est pourquoi au nom de mon groupe je
défendrai plusieurs amendements sur des
sujets essentiels notamment à propos du
dispositif de soutien à l'aide
alimentaire nous élargirons le
dispositif de soutien aux éleveurs
beauvin nous proposerons d'abaisser le
prélèvement sur le fond de roulement des
chambres de commerce et d'industrie pour
préserver leurs ressources de renforcer
le dispositif d'aide universelle
d'urgence pour les victimes de violence
conjugale d'élargir le taux réduit de
TVA et la création et la créance
d'impôts sur les sociétés sur le
logement locatif intermédiaire nous
proposerons enfin un taux de TVA réduit
à 5,5 % sur les préservatifs masculins
et féminins mes chers collègues nous
sommes prêts pour un débat enrichissant
sans contradiction et je pense notamment
au au sujet de la CVAE parce qu'on peut
pas être devant les chefs d'entrepris et
regretter que ça ne va pas assez vite et
quand on est devant les élus locaux que
regretter cette suppression donc oui mes
chers collègues prie pour un débat
enrichissant respectueux et sans langue
de bois merci merci la parole est à
présent à notre collègue Thierry kozic
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain pour 6
minutes monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission monsieur le rapporteur
général mes chers collègues nous voici
réunis pour entamer l'examen du 2uxè
projet de loi de finance de cette
législature et cela sans la menace de
débat avorté par le déclenchement du
493 ce dont je me
réjouis monsieur le ministre ce budget
représente un vertigineux exercice
d'équilibriste tant des problématiques
quasi antagoniste
s'oppose en effet sa construction fait
ressortir un trilème entre transition
écologique cohésion sociale et austérité
budgétaire ce triangle d'incompatibilité
démontre trois choses tout d'abord votre
volonté chronique de baisser les impôts
qui entrent en collision avec celle de
réduire le déficit public ensuite que
les investissements verts proposés sont
loin de répondre aux objectifs de
décarbonation enfin que les baisses de
dépenses publiques à travers plusieurs
pistes d'économie fragilise notre notre
modèle social et en particulier les
classes
populaires ce budget c'est aussi celui
de tous les renoncements l'année 2023
été marqué par des débats de fond
structurel dans notre société quelle
place donner à l'héritage dans la lutte
contre les inégalités de patrimoine
comment taxer de manière plus équitable
les multinationales comment lutter de
manière plus efficiente contre la fraude
fiscale au rythme de nos questions
hebdomadaires au gouvernement toujours
un même mot sur le banc des ministres
nous traiterons ces questions dans le
prochain budget
autonnal nous y sommes et je dois dire
que la déception est à la hauteur de
l'espérance que vos plans de
communication avaient suscité mais je
dois le reconnaître il est des
renoncement qui sonnent comme des aveux
et que nous partageons avec vous je
parle bien entendu de votre renoncement
à totalement supprimé la CVAE cet année
décalant sa suppression totale à la fin
du kakeda en
2027 ce renoncement est la preuve que
votre obstination dogmatique à vouloir
baisser les impôts de production
s'arrête tout net face au mur des
réalités budgétaires cette annulation de
baisse et symptômatique de la
contradiction qui vous anime en la
matière car disons-le franchement soit
on considère cette suppression
nécessaire car c'est un outil de relance
économique comme vous nous le répétez
depuis 6 ans et dans ce cas il ne faut
pas perdre de temps soit cette baisse
est inutile tant elle n'est pas
efficiente et dont on peut attendre et
donc on peut attendre 4 ans force c'est
de constater que le choix qui est le
vôtre fait office même d'aveu car si par
cette annulation vous commencez à
esquisser un début de prise de
conscience de l'inanité de la de votre
politique de l'offre d'autres rapports
après apport après rapport se charge
plus frontalement frontalement de vous
le dire de France stratégie en passant
par la Cour des comptes tous aboutissent
aux mêmes conclusions maintenir l'ISF
aurait rapporté 6,3 milliards d'euros en
2022 nous ne contestons pas le fait que
les entreprises sont là pour créer de la
richesse mais monsieur le ministre nous
sommes au regret de vous rappeler que
l'État est là pour créer de la
justice cet argent pourrait financer de
grands chantiers car il n'en manque pas
par exemple nous pensons qu'au cœur du
budget devrait figurer la la bifurcation
écologique pour atteindre l'objectif de
neutralité carbone les économistes
pisanifée et mafous que le Président de
la République a lui-même nommé estime
nécessaire un investissement public à
hauteur de 34 milliards d'euros en
conséquence les 7 milliards que vous que
vous proposez dans ce budget semble bien
dérisoire néanmoins nous souhaitons tout
de même contribuer à la recherche de
financement nous vous proposons donc de
donner un avis favorable à notre
amendement visant à installer un ISF
vert comme le préconise d'ailleurs ce
même rapport votre incapacité à résoudre
ce triangle d'incompatibilité vous
pousse à l'improvisation constante vous
aviez prévu 16 milliards d'économie mais
au dernier moment vous avez demandé aux
oppositions et à votre majorité relative
parlementaire de trouver 1 milliard
d'euros d'économie supplémentaire
improvisation toujours quant à la
défaveur d'une hausse des prix des
carburants la première ministre a sans
avoir concerté quiconque annoncé que les
distributeurs vendrai à perte le car
urant les enseignes ont beau se livrer à
une virulente guerre des prix leurs
patrons ont adressé à la première
ministre une fin de non recevoir vous
savez le besoin en financement est
colossal et nous devons nous donner les
moyens de trouver des recettes
supplémentaire à ce titre qu'en est-il
de la lutte contre l'évasion fiscale
malgré un grand plan antifraude annoncé
en grande pompe avant l'été les mesures
sont loin d'être à la hauteur des enjeux
cette cause devrait être prior ire et
donc massivement doté de moyens humain
matériels et financiers car elle recèle
de colossales recettes potentielles nous
défendrons des amendements en ce sens
car la politique fiscale visant à faire
contribuer tout le monde à hauteur de
ses facultés contributives n'est pas
votre
mantra l'exemple quasi caricatural
réside dans votre volonté d'exonérer
d'impôts les fédérations sportives je
rappelle que la FIFA avec un chiffre
d'affaires record de 7,6 milliards de
dollars dispose de moyens subst pour ne
pas avoir bénéficier de telles
exemptions pour conclure monsieur le
ministre comme vous avez je cite Bruno
leopère souhaiter responsabiliser les
oppositions dans la construction du
budget en leur demandant de trouver un
milliard d'économie le groupe socialiste
du Sénat tient aussi à vous aider nous
tenons à vous aider à trouver non pas
des économies mais des recettes
supplémentaires mais pour se faire nous
avons besoin de vous nous invitons à
donner des avis favorables aux
amendements de notre groupe disant à
instaurer un pfu à hauteur de 40 % un
ISF vert une taxation des super profits
et la liste est trop longue pour qu'elle
soit exhaustive vous l'aurez compris le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain s'opposera à ce budget que
nous trouvons iniique tant il fait peser
de manière unilatérale les efforts sur
les classes moyennes tout en favorisant
les plus aisés de nos de notre pays seul
un budget emprunte justice fiscale et
sociale pourrait emporter notre vote
et en l'état nous en sommes très
loin merci la parole est à notre
collègue Christine lavard pour le groupe
les républicains pour 15
[Applaudissements]
minutes alors monsieur le ministre dans
le dossier de presse de vos gouvernement
ce PLF 2024 répond au défi de demain il
met l'accent sur la lutte contre
l'inflation la protection du pouvoir
d'achat des Français la baisse du
déficit public et les investissements
pour préparer l'avenir tout
particulièrement la transition
écologique monsieur le ministre c'est
bien connu qui troupe embrasse mal et
trains non ce PLF ne fait pas face à
l'urgence écologique la forte baisse des
dépenses défavorables en 2024 s'explique
uniquement par l'extinction progressive
des dispositifs de soutien au
consommateur moins de 7 % des dépenses
de ce budget soutiennent la transition
écologique de notre pays les 3/4 des
dépenses sont considérées comme neutres
mais c'est logique au regard du poids
des transferts sociaux et des charges de
personnel dans le budget de l'État si
l'État était moins omnipotent dans la
vie des Français la part des dépenses
évaluables serait nécessairement plus
élevée une part aussi faible de dépenses
notables interroge sur la portée
opérationnelle du budget vert d'ailleurs
personne ni l'administration ni les
parlementaires ne se réfèrent jamais à
ce document surtout le le gouvernement
oublie de l'actualiser lorsqu'il s'agit
de la loi de règlement en 2021 comme en
2022 et encore en 2023 les dépenses
vertes exécutées sont nettement
inférieures à celles qui ont été votées
un seul exemple ma prime rennove le
projet de loi fin gestion qui a été
définitivement adopté hier a annulé 0,4
milliard d'AE et 1 milliard de CP pour
2023 ce budget vert cache l'absence d'un
cadre de financement pluriannuel pour
faire converger les trajectoir
environnementale et la trajectoire des
finances publiques les investissements à
couvrir par l'État par les ménages par
les entreprises sont considérables et
doivent être anticipés 50 à 70 milliards
d'euros pour les 50 sites industriels
les plus émetteurs de CO2 80 milliards
en 2030 contre 55 milliards aujourd'hui
pour les collectivités on ne peut donc
que saluer l'introduction au cours de la
navette parlementaire d'un article dans
la LPFP qui va obliger le gouvernement à
transmettre chaque année une stratégie
pluriannuelle qui définit les
financements de la transition écologique
et de la politique énergétique cette
réflexion est importante car la
transition énergétique va avoir des
conséquences significatives sur nos
équilibres financiers prenons un seul
exemple celui du financement de la
politique de l'eau la sobriété a
entraîné une baisse de 10 % de la
consommation sur une année mais dans le
même temps les recettes ont reculé de la
même proportion or il y a une estimation
de près de 3 milliards d'euros
d'investissement pendant 5 ans pour
adapter nos réseaux au changement
climatique malheureusement ce projet de
loi de finance n'apporte aucune réponse
l'article 49 on des siè relève
excusez-moi de le dire d'un simple coup
de peinture pour emprunter les mots du
rapporteur général la possibilité
désormais offerte aux collectivités de
joindre un at des engagements financiers
concourrents à la transition écologique
à son budget primitif ne changera rien
sur le coût et le poids de la dettes sur
ses finances rien d'ailleurs
n'interdisait à ce jour que les rapports
budgétaires contiennent des graphiques
pour identif cet endettement l'action
des collectivités est d'autant plus
difficile que le gouvernement continue
de financer par àou la communication
autour de la flexibilité du fond vert de
son adaptation au réalité locale se
heurte au fait la réorientation massive
des crédits de 2024 vers la rénovation
du bâti scolaire à hauteur de 500
millions d'euros délai très brefs pour
déposer les dossiers alors pourquoi ne
pas mettre en place à l'instar de ce qui
existe pour la politique du tourisme une
fiscalité affectée avec une obligation
de budget dédiée comme chaque année le
Sénat vous fera des propositions en ce
sens plus généralement notre système de
financement marche sur la tête près de 2
milliards d'aêes de l'État visant à
titre principal la transition écologique
des entreprises ont été versé par 5
opérateurs au travers de 340 dispositifs
différents elles ont été créées par
stratification progressive sans réelle
réflexion sur la cohérence d'ensemble
alors que l'inspection de que le rapport
de l'Inspection générale des finances
appelle en tout premier lieu à une
discipline d'évaluation demain deux
ministres eux iront dévoiler une
plateforme dédiée à la à un accès
simplifié des entreprises à cesz avant
toute réflexion sur le fond il est
pourtant urgent d'agir sur la
décarbonation de notre économie car
demain notre système financier pourrait
empâtir en effet comme le soulligne une
note de la Banque de France les fonds
d'investissement et par là même les
compagnies d'assurance sont fortement
exposé au risques associés au changement
climatique en particulier au risques de
transition notre groupe ne pense pas que
l'écologie doit rimer avec la
décroissance pour notre groupe
l'écologie doit coïncider avec une
meilleure croissance et une souveraineté
industrielle et malheureusement non ce
PLF ne garantit pas la souveraineté de
la France dans tous les domaines nous
commençons tout juste à réagir avec
l'évolution des modalités d'attribution
du bonus automobile en 2024 je regrette
d'ailleurs que le ministre le maire ne
soit pas là pour m'entendre alors que
les premiers véhicules électriques
abordables des constructeurs français
prenduit dans l'Union européenne vont
arriver prochainement sur les chaînes de
production les crédits accordés au bonus
et à la prime à la conversion en 2024
seront en diminution par rapport à ceux
exécutés en 2023 cette année une part
très significative tenez-vous bien des
1,9 milliards d'euros sont allés
soutenir l'industrie chinoise j'ose le
dire c'est scandaleux sur t que nous
vous avions prévenu surtout quand on
sait que Tesla ou les marques chinoises
pour réduire leur coût de fabrication
conçoivent des batteries non recyclable
je pourrais poursuivre avec d'autres
exemples entre 2015 et 2020 les
importations de pompes à chaleur
chinoise ont augmenté de 17 % par an
dans l'Union européenne par ailleurs les
pompes à chaleur assemblé en France sont
produites avec des composants
électroniques et des matières premières
très largement importées d'Asie ma prime
renve et les C2 eux ont financé en 2022
près de 1,4 milliards d'euros
d'équipement et de matériaux de
rénovation énergétique importé comme
certains monsieur le ministre je pense
que la communication gouvernementale
autour du Black Friday aurait dû inciter
les consommateur à acheter français et à
acheter durable plutôt que de ne pas
acheter mais malheureusement on ne peut
pas consommer et on ne peut pas exporter
ce que l'on ne produit pas la part de
l'industrie manufacture dans la valeur
ajoutée totale a baissé de près d'un/ers
en 20 ans la réindustrialisation ne doit
pas se faire à tout prix les observation
de la Cour des comptes sur le volet
relocalisation industrielle de
francerance sont sévères les objectifs
pluriannuels de l'instrument ont nuit à
la qualité du sublage des subventions
sur lequel pourtant repose l'efficacité
de la politique de
réindustrialisation la souveraineté
industrielle la souveraineté elle est
industrielle mais elle est aussi
financière et de grands défis nous
attendent fin 2022 47 % de la dette
publique française était detenue par des
étrangers contre 39 % pour l'ensemble
des principaux pays émetteurs de la zone
euro contre 23 % aux États-Unis et
comment cette part va-t-elle évoluer
avec le désengagement progressif de la
Banque de France qui détient aujourd'hui
709 milliards d'en cours de dette les
années qui viennent vont voir la France
entrer dans un cycle infernal avec des
niveaux de dettes arrivant à échéance
qu'il faudra refinancer à hauteur de
plus de 200 milliards d'euros par an en
2025 et en 2026 selon des estimations de
l'rapp le coût de la dette dans le
déficit budgétaire va passer de 13 % en
2019 à 50 % en
2027 l'urgence devrait donc être avec
une telle charge de la dette en 2027 de
parvenir à l'équilibre primaire des
comptes plus vite le plus vite possible
en agissant prioritairement sur les
dépenses alors que le gouvernement a
peiné à trouver des économies pour 2024
appelant les parlementaires à en faire 1
milliard de propositions supplémentaires
12 milliards d'euros doivent être
trouvés pour 2025 pour tenir la
trajectoire de réduction du déficit
public j'ai cru comprendre que le
gouvernement mettait beaucoup d'espoir
dans la revue des dépenses publiques
alors vous vous souvenez monsieur le
ministre que j'ai eu l'occasion de faire
un petit état des lieux de la version
numéro 1 dans ma discussion générale euh
de la LPFP et notamment des résultats
très mitigés vu les échos que j'ai eu de
la réunion de mardi matin sur le sujet
j'ai un peu de crainte sur la deuxème
exercice alors dimanche monsieur le
ministre avec votre collègue Bruno Le
Maire vous nous indiquiez avoir trouvé
une recette miracle la vente des bijous
de famille malheureusement c'est un
fusil à un coût par ailleurs le levier
des recette fiscal ne pourra pas être
actionné sans détruire notre
compétitivité il reste donc un seul
levier celui des économies tout au long
de la discussion de ce PLF nous aurons
l'occasion de vous démontrer que la
trajectoire des finances publ voté par
le Sénat dans la LPFP n'était pas
irréaliste qu'il est possible de faire
plus de 5 milliards d'économies dès 2024
malheureusement à la clarté des enjeux
la communication budgétaire préfère
souvent l'obscurité des mesures
relatives vous parlez en point de PIB
c'est une grandeur qui permet
d'entretenir le flou mais c'est une
grandeur qui n'est pas pratiquée par les
français eux ils connaissent le mettre
le kilo l'euro c'est une grandeur qui
est absurde comme l'a rappelé d'ailleurs
Vincent de lae pas plus tard qu'en début
de semaine puisque le PIB est constitué
à 30 % par la dépense publique mais en
point de PIB tout passe mieux le déficit
s'améliore il passe de 4,9 à 4,4 %
pourtant en euros il reste stable de 150
milliards à 150 milliards le taux de
prélèvement lu obligatoire lui passe de
44 à 44,4 % en 2027 un petit chiffre
après la virgule qui cache une hausse de
10 % et combien de milliards prév en
plus la charge d'intérêt de la dette
elle va passer de 1,3 % en 2023 à 2,6 %
en 2027 une hausse en apparence minime
qui cache pourtant un plus que
doublement de 37 à 84 milliards d'euros
les ménages monsieur le ministre eux ils
parlent en euros le gouvernement lui il
parle en point de payb ce qui lui permet
de ne pas dire que ses dépenses seront
de 30 % supérieur à ses recettes cette
fragilité de nos finances nous rend
moins fort pour discuter sur la scène
européenne de la réforme du pacte de
stabilité croissance les critères
pourtant plus souples proposés par la
Commission européenne feraient très
certainement consensus parmi les
États-membres s'il n'y avait pas les
cancres que sont l'Italie et la France
notre souveraineté elle repose aussi sur
notre image auprès de nos partenaires
européens si ce projet de loi de finance
comprend des mesures immédiates de
soutien des Français à l'inflation nous
remarquons qu'elle reste encore
empreinte de la philosophie du quoi
qu'il en coûte l'objectif de
souveraineté nous nous impose pourtant
d'adopter sans faillir le mantra du
combien ça coûte c'est la raison qui
soutend les dispositifs de révision du
dispositif de soutien des particuliers
face au niveau des prix de l'électricité
en le ciblant pour parti sur les ménages
les plus modestes c'est beaucoup moins
populaire que l'arrosage tout asimute
mais c'est beaucoup plus respectueux des
générations futures en effet Monsieur le
Ministre non ce PLF ne soutient pas les
Français les récentes discussions du
pfss illustre à quel point les
générations futures sont les grandes
oubliées de la politique peut-être par
parce que ce n'est pas elles qui vont
être appelées aux urnes dans quelques
mois ces générations ce sont elles qui
devront financer la charge de dette ce
sont elles aussi qui auront apporté le
vieillissement de la population selon
les frapp le seul coût des allocations
versées pour soutenir financièrement les
personnes âgées qui perdront en
autonomie pourrait dépasser 10 milliards
d'euros à l'horizon 2040 soit une hausse
de 80 % par rapport à 2020 les dépenses
de les finances des département ne
suffiront pas par les enjeux financiers
qu'elle soutend la loi de programmation
sur la question du grand âge est une
urgence au même titre que celle sur le
financement de la transition écologique
je n'ose rappeler ici qu'il s'agissait
une promesse de campagne du président
Macron en 2017 6 ans ont passé et la
situation est désormais catastrophique
les deux plus grandes entreprises côté
du secteur ont eu besoin d'un plan de
sauvetage la majorité des demis
établissements privés membres du
syndicat sinerpa finiront l'année en
perte 100 millions d'euros ont dû être
débloqués en urgence cet été la ministre
horore berger elle-même reconnaît qu'il
faut se poser des questions de plus long
terme sur le financement de la branche
autonomie en effet les 015 point de CSG
désormais attribué à la CNSA servaient
jusqu'à présent au remboursement de la
dette sur la sécurité sociale via la
CRDS celle-ci je vous le reconnais est
censée disparaître en 2033 mais la
persistance des déficits pose des
questions sur sa prolongation et donc
sur son financement selon le FMI la
facture annuelle de la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique de l'effort
supplémentaire de défense provoqué par
la multiplication des tensions
géopolitiques et du vieillissement
démographique pourrait atteindre 7,5 %
de PIB pour les pays de l'OCDE ces gens
jeux qui sont devant nous nous appelle à
davantage de rigueur dans la gestion des
deniers publicqus alors Monsieur le
Ministre méditons ensemble ces quelques
paroes de Napoléon qui en ce moment fait
la une des journaux il a dit lorsqu'un
gouver gouvernement est dépendant des
banquiers pour l'argent ce sont ces
derniers et non pas les dirigeants du
gouvernement qui contrôlent la situation
puisque la main qui donne est au-dessus
de la main qui reçoit l'argent n'a pas
de patrie les financiers n'ont pas de
patriotisme et non pas de déessence leur
unique objectif est le gain méditons-le
à l'ône de notre
dette
merci la parole est à présent monsieur
Joshua auchochard
pour les sédateurs ne figurant sur la
liste d'aucun groupe pour 5
minutes monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues c'est
vrai que tout à l'heure en attendant
monsieur le ministre Bruno Le Maire qui
a déserté ses bans sa prise de parole
ressemblait un peu à un discours de de
campagne oubliant un candidat oubliant
effectivement qui devait être au pouvoir
depuis 6 ans Nietzsche disait parfois
les gens ne veulent pas entendre la
vérité parce qu'ils ne veulent pas que
leurs illusions soient détruites
monsieur le ministre c'est bien un
budget d'illusion que vous présentez
devant le Sénat bilan de votre politique
est celle de vos prédécesseurs siégeant
largement sur ses bancs la France
affiche le triste bilan d'une dette
dépassant les 3000 milliards de dette
pour faire passer la pilule vous basez
votre projet sur une croissance
illusoire reconnue unanimement comme
optimiste je dirais même fantaisiste par
les plus hautes instances
macroéconomiques du pays par ailleurs la
France a atteint des record de
prélèvement obligatoire et d'impôts avec
selon Eurostat 47 % du produit intérieur
brut passant dans les prélèvements
obligatoires la France affiche triste
record d'être le pays européen le plus
imposé après le Danemark les Français
consentent encore à l'impôt et
souhaitent participer à l'effort
national mais ont-ils un retour sur
l'investissement malheureusement la
réponse est non les Français voi chaque
jour le délitement du service public et
la pression délirante d'une
administration la vôre tatillonne et
procédurière toujours moins service
public et une complexité administrative
pour faire avancer quelconque projet un
hôpital et des soignants à bout de
souffle des déserts médicaux pour plus
d'un tiers des Français qui refusent
souvent de se soigner l'abandon de nos
outr mè je pense en particulier à maotte
où l'accès à l'eau est une difficulté de
tous les jours où la sécurité de nos
concitoyens Maoré est un défi de chaque
instant des enseignants et notre école
rép républaine pilier de notre état où
le pacte républicain qui représente nos
valeurs intemporelles de liberté
d'égalité de fraternité sont remis en
cause par un fondamentalisme islamique
qui gangrainene notre vivre ensemble une
immigration non contrôlée qui met à rue
d'épreuve nos ressources et la capacité
d'assimilation nous devons lier nos
valeurs d'humanité avec l'Harmonie de
notre nation alors que la situation
financière de la France est sensiblement
dégradée interrogeant sa soutenabilité à
moyen terme vous camoufler à coup de 40
93 la gravité de la situation de nos
comptes publics vous êtes dans
l'autosatisfaction permanente par
ailleurs vous voulez jouer les bons
élèves de l'Union européenne à qui les
Français ont donné en 2023 plus de 24
milliards d'euros sur ce montant sans
cesse croissant vous présentez au hasard
une baisse de 3 milliards d'euros de
cette dîme bruxelloise écran de fumée
électoraliste de la macronie pour éviter
un désastre électoral le 9 juin prochain
c'est peine perdu mais les Français ne
sont pas DUP et on l'espoir avec Marine
Le Pen d'une alternance prochaine qui
devient et oui encore fair vous y habit
é qui devient d'année en année de
déficit en déficit une nécessité
toujours plus urgente à ce sujet les
sénateurs assembl nationale proposeront
et soutiendront durant cet examen du
projet de loi de finance tous les
amendements de bon sens nous pour faire
payer ceux qu'il doivent et surtout
rendre leur argent au français ainsi
nous proposerons l'urgente baisse de la
TVA sur l'énergie et sur les produits de
première nécessité pour enfin desserer
les taux qui pèsent sur nos compatriotes
les plus modestes nous agirons aussi
pour augmenter leur pouvoir d'achat et
proposerons la mesure vital d'un gel des
cotisations patronales en échangeun
augmentation de 10 % des salaires enfin
la natalité pilier central de toute
prospérité sera défendu et encouragé en
remettant l'universalité des allocations
familiales honteusement spolié par la
gauche aux familles françaises conscient
de la situation dégradée de nos finances
publiques le rassemblement national vous
proposera également des mesures pour
faire rentrer cet argent qui manque t
dans nos caisses ainsi nous défendrons
la taxation du patrimoine immatériel et
des super profits le capital qui a
toutes les faveurs de votre gouvernement
doit aussi être mis à contribution à
l'effort national enfin nous demandrons
que l'onteuse contribution financière à
l'Union européenne soit diminuée chers
membres du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre la chambre hutete ne peut être
muselée comme l'a été l'Assemblée
nationale par le seul chiffre qui semble
avoir grâce à vos yeux le 493 dans cette
chambre cet article ne peut être dégainé
nous appelons tous les sénateurs sur ces
bancs à entendre nos propositions et
soutenir cell qui vont dans le bon sens
l'intérêt national doit transcender les
petits intérêts électoraux comme les
calculs d'écuries politiques discrédit
pour conclure redonnons espoir et
espérance au peuple de France en
dépassant nos divergences partisanes je
vous
remercie merci la parole est à notre
collègue Emmanuel Capu pour le groupe
les indépendants pour 10
minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre qui reste monsieur le président
de la commission des
finances monsieur le rapporteur non
j'avais écrit messieurs les ministres
monsieur le rapporteur général mes chers
collègues la France est un paradis
peuplé de gens qui se croient en enfer
ça n'est pas moi qui le dit c'est
Sylvain Tesson mais je crois qu'il a
raison
tellement raison même qu'il est
difficile de convaincre les Français
qu'ils ne vivent pas en
enfer difficile de convaincre certains
sénateurs également mais au plan
budgétaire mes chers collègues qu'est-ce
que
l'enfer l'enfer c'est quand les
prélèvements obligatoires atteignent des
niveaux confiscatoires c'est quand la
dette explose c'est quand l'inflation
s'emballe c'est quand les services
publics ne fonctionnent plus alors même
qu'ils n'ont jamais bénéficié de moyens
financiers aussi importants c'est quand
le pays semble au bord de
l'implosion c'est ça
l'enfer et au contraire qu'est-ce que le
paradis au plan
budgétaire le paradis c'est quand les
impôts sont suffisamment bas pour
permettre aux gens de vivre dignement de
leur travail et aux entreprises d'être
compétitives et innovantes c'est quand
les services publics se modernisent
c'est quand les comptes sont maîtrisés
et que la signature de l'état inspire
confiance alors mes chers collègues
Sylvain Tesson a-t-il
raison à mon avis c'est fort
probable bien sûr il n'est pas difficile
de trouver les éléments prouvant que la
France est effectivement un enfer
budgétaire et notre collègue Lavarde en
a cité quelquesuns
abondamment d'ailleurs c'est peut-être
l'opinion qui domine chez nos
concitoyens et chez certains d'entre
vous avec plus de 3 milliards de 3000
milliards d'euros de dett publique un
déficit chronique une balance
commerciale structurellement déficitaire
un taux d'inflation supérieur au taux de
croissance une dépense publique à 55 %
du PIB un taux de prélèvement
obligatoire parmi les plus élevés du
monde des services publics sousension un
taux de chômage qui pourrait repartir à
la hausse il y a quoi il y a de quoi
adesser un tableau
alarmant mais la France semble aussi au
plan budgétaire un paradis sur terre
pour s convaincre le plus simple est
sans doute de s'intéresser à ce que les
étrangers pensent de notre pays selon le
prix Nobel l'économie Paul grugman la
France est le pays qui a le mieux géré
la crise selon
derpegel la France c'est l'Allemagne en
mieux alors que l'économie peine à
redémarrer outre rein la France c'est le
pays qui attire en Europe le plus
d'investissements étrangers les
notations restent excellentes le taux de
chômage n'a jamais été aussi bas depuis
un DEM siècle l'inflation reflue
doucement certes mais elle reflue en
passant de 4,9 % cette année à 2,6 %
l'an
prochain mes chers collègues je n'irai
pas plus loin dans l'exégèse de Sylvin
Tesson l'important n'est pas là me
semble-t-il au-delà du tableau que
chacun pourra adresser aujourd'hui
l'important c'est de savoir le cap que
nous souhaitons fixer pour la suite
l'exercice est difficile car les nuages
cela a été dit Sam C au-dessus de notre
avenir j'identifie au moins trois types
de
menaces la plus évidente c'est la menace
sécuritaire
elle s'affirme à l'extérieur de nos
frontières bien sûr mais aussi à
l'intérieur partout dans le monde les
attaques contre les démocraties se
multiplient en France l'explosion de la
délinquence inquiète jusque dans nos
campagnes nous faisons aussi face à à la
menace du déclass économique et à celle
du délitement social ces trois
menaces sécuritair économique et social
sont bien évidemment liés c'est pourquoi
nous devons y apporter une réponse
claire et cohérente à mon sens la
solution tient en trois mots un État
fort un état pas omnipotent cher
collègue Christine Lavarde mais un État
fort notre objectif doit donc être de
renforcer l'État je crois mes chers
collègues que le budget pour 2024 y
contribue un État fort c'est d'abord et
surtout un état puissant dans l'exercice
de ces missions
régaliennes
justice forces de l'ordre forces armées
sur ces trois volets les moyens
mobilisés augmentent considérablement
c'est une excellente nouvelle ces
augmentations s'inscrivent dans les
trajectoires définies par les trois lois
de programmation que nous avons voté la
loi de progam programmation du ministère
de l'Intérieur la loi de programmation
militaire la loi de programmation de la
justice au-delà de ces trois fonction
régaliennees clé le PLF contient
plusieurs mesures de lutte contre la
fraude fiscale elles sont bienvenues
l'État doit être fort fort avec tous les
citoyens et pas seulement avec les
faibles ou alors il n'y a plus de
justice notre groupe vous proposera
d'ailleurs d'affermir ces mesures par
exemple en rendant automatique
l'application de la peine complémentaire
en cas fraude fiscale
aggravé tout ce qui renforce l'État dans
ses missions régaliennes est bienvenu à
contrario mes chers collègu tout ce qui
l'empêche est malvenu c'est pourquoi
notre groupe reste fidèle à sa ligne
budgétaire il faut continuer à mettre de
l'ordre dans nos comptes un état en
déficit chronique dans les dont les
recettes représentent à peine plus de la
moitié des dépenses ne peut pas être
l'état fort que nous appelons nos vœux
le Rapporteur général a annoncé
plusieurs milliards d'économies c'est
ambitieux le groupe Les Indépendants
partage cet objectif nous prendrons
notre part plus que notre part monsieur
le rapporteur général puisque comme vous
le savez les sur les crédit de la
mission travail emploi dont je suis le
rapporteur avec jus c'est déjà 1
milliard d'économie que nous proposons
sur les 5 milliards que propose la
commission des
finances nous prendrons donc toute notre
part
ce n'est certes pas suffisant au regard
des 144 milliards du déficit public mais
c'est un début notre groupe vous
proposera d'autres mesures d'économie
dès la première partie mais il y a des
dépenses monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues il y a des dépenses qui
peuvent rapporter gros pour répondre à
la menace de déclassement économique
l'État doit se faire stratège il doit
indiquer par des orientations claires
les secteurs stratégiques sur lesquels
nous devons investir massivement pour
préparer notre avenir à cet égard
notre groupe a soutenu toutes les
initiatives prises par le gouvernement
pour accélérer la réindustrialisation du
pays nous continuerons de le faire et
nous serons force de proposition en la
matière sur ce point fidèle à notre
position des années passées reporter la
suppression de la CV nous
interroge le plus dur avait été fait
monsieur le ministre garantir aux
collectivités locales une ressource
pérenne et dynamique revenir sur ce sur
ce calendrier nous le craignons c'est
brouiller une stratégie qui avait le
mérite de la clarté
au même titre que le crédit d'impôt pour
les investissements dans l'industrie
verte ou le plan d'épargne avenir climat
toutes les dépenses qui accélèent la
réindustrialisation de notre territoire
sont des dépenses avec un retour sur
investissement rapide et massif nous
améliorerons notre bilan carbone global
nous rétablirons notre balance
commerciale nous continuerons à créer de
l'emploi et à innover et surtout ce sont
nos territoir qui en profiteront
pleinement miser sur la
réindustrialisation c'est offrir àé
territoire et notamment à nos
territoires ruraux des perspectives
nouvelles c'est leur faire une promesse
d'attractivité et de compétitivité c'est
bien là que se trouve la réponse à la
menace de désagrégation
sociale miser sur nos territoires c'est
renforcer la cohésion sociale de notre
pays à cet égard vous avez monsieur le
ministre des alliés que vous auriez tort
de négliger ces alliés seront toujours
au rendez-vous des solutions qui
fonctionnent sur le terrain ces alliés
ce sont les collectivités locales
leur message est clair elles veulent des
politiques frappées au coin du bon sens
elles veulent une relation de confiance
avec l'État le Congrès des Maires leur
offre comme chaque année une caisse de
résonance en pleine séquence budgétaire
l'augmentation de la dotation globale de
fonctionnement à hauteur de 220 millions
d'euros est de ce point de vue une
excellente nouvelle pour les élus locaux
après la crise sanitaire et le Plic et
le pic inflationniste une augmentation
de leur moyens aurait été une stagnation
pardon de leurs moyens aurait été
malvenu plusieurs autres mesures devront
renforcer la la relation de confiance je
pense bien sûr à la redéfinition des RR
dont nous aurons l'occasion de débattre
longuement mais aussi à la rétrocession
aux collectivités des amendes prélevées
dans les zones à faible émission et bien
sûr au renforcement du pacte de
stabilité au profit des communes
nouvelles sur tous ces sujets mes chers
collègues je ne doute pas que le Sénat
sera force de propositions
le groupe Les Indépendants aborde
sereinement ce projet de loi de finance
pour 2024 avec une boussole très clair
un étap sur ses missions régaliennes et
en confiance avec les collectivités
locales je vous remercie merci la parole
est à présent notre collègue Nathalie
Goulet pour le groupe Union centriste
pour 5
[Applaudissements]
minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues d'abord je
voudis remercier Bernard rcro qui a
permis l'inversion de
l'ordre de parole me permettant de de
rentrer dans mon bon département
monsieur le ministre notre groupe va
vous aider à équiliberer votre budget en
vous donnant quelques moyens de renfler
nos caisses grâce à la lutte contre la
fraude fiscale les chiffres sont
astronomique 80 à 120 milliards manque
aux caisses de l'État et notre groupe
fait de ces sujets un axe fort je salue
tout d'abord les dispositions des
articles 19 20 et 21 avec une petite
tendresse pour l'article 22 relatif au
prix de transfert
euh dans le PLF à la fois sur la
première partie mais aussi sur le suite
nous nous vous proposerons quelques
dispositifs de matière de matière
regrettable persistante et anormale dit
la Cour des comptes dans son rapport de
2023 nous ne disposons d'aucun outil
d'évaluation de la fraude fiscale alors
vous avez réuni après l'excellente
impulsion de Gabriel Atal un groupe de
travail mais toujours pas d'instance
permanente pour cette évaluation et
pendant ce temps les voleurs courent
monsieur le ministre un fraudeur heureux
est un fraudeur qui revient le document
de politique transversale qui nous est
remis ne ne remplit pas son rôle dans
son intégralité l'explication notamment
des des crédits du programme 156 sont
insuffisants les différents acteurs et
services concourrant à la lutte contre
l'évasion fiscale qui sont financés par
d'autres programmes ne figurent pas dans
le document de politique transversale
qui est techniquement fait pour ça
quelques exemples tracf dépend du du
programme 218 conduite et pilotage des
politiques économiques la brigade
nationale de la répression de la
délinquence financière
bnrdf dépend du programme
176 n'est pas non plus dans le le
document e le budget du parquet national
financier qui est quand même un sujet
important dépend du programme 166 ne
figure pas non plus dans le document de
politique transversale donc avoir un
document de politique transversale c'est
très important qui soit in complet le
rend moins
opérant quelques
éléments de fond la fraude à l'arbitrage
des dividendes 150 milliards au plan
mondial 33 milliards pour la France
entre entre 2000 et 2020 nous allons
vous proposer au groupe de l'Union
centriste un amendement retoqué
plusieurs fois mais j'espère que la
descente du parquet national financier
au printemps dernier vous
motivera le le ministre Atal qui vous a
précdé précédé annoncer un redressement
d'environ 2 milliards et demi d'euros le
deuxième point monsieur le ministre et
vous ne serez pas surpris concerne une
véritable lutte contre la délinquence
financière et les paradis fiscaux avec
un travail de fond sur les conventions
fiscales internationales un scandale une
annonce Nicolas sarkoi avait annoncé à
daauville les paradis fiscaux c'est fini
force et se constater qu'ils ne se sont
jamais aussi bien portés la Suisse
malgré ses problèmes et ses promesses le
Luxembourg les portsfanc aux portes de
l'Europe et en Europe le
litenstein évidemment jersey nos amis de
Dubaï qui bat ce des milliards en
roubles ou en euros peu importe la liste
grise n'est pas non plus plus
satisfaisante on y retrouve des pays
amis comme l'Arménie bon et Israël et
toujours rien ni sur Dubaï ni sur la
Grande-Bretagne post brexit les règles
monsieur le ministre pour sortir de la
liste des territoires non coopératifs ne
sont pas sérieuse il s'agit simplement
de conclure une convention peu importe
qu'il y ait un acte vous savez que il y
a pas d'amour sans acte d'amour on
devrait appliquer la même chose aux
États et territoires non coopératifs je
vais vous donner un petit exemple
l'oligarque Monsieur T s'est acheté un
Falcon 2000 bon 28 millions de dollars
une paille il l'a revendu pour un 900 LX
38 millions de dollars une paille et
enfin achète un 7 x 48 millions de
dollars toujours une paille ces
appareils produits par dassassau ont été
livrés au Bourget sans que Monsieur T ne
paye la moindre TVA ces achat ayant été
effectués par des sociétés écran
enregistré dans l'île de manne en a
achetant ses avions monsieur té a fauté
la TVA à hauteur de 18 million et demi
d'euros c'est beaucoup d'argent la
prolifération des pardon voilà la
prolifération des jets privés est
synonyme de fraude fiscale il en est de
même pour les yacht et le célèbre
leasing maltais au nez et à la barbe des
contribuables européens ayons un débat
régulier sur ces questions et sur les
conventions fiscales au lieu d'avaliser
sans aucun pouvoir les conventions
fiscales qui nous sont proposées Éric
bet l'a d'ailleurs extrêmement bien
démontré lors de la dernier du dernier
débat sur la convention fiscale qui
semblait complètement anodine avec le
Danemark et la Grèce et qui en réalité
masquait des avantage nombreux pour les
plus gros acteurs du trafic maritime
est-ce que j'ai dépassé mon temps de
parole oui j'aurais beaucoup à vous dire
sur j'aurais beaucoup à vous dire
notamment sur les conventions
judiciaires d'intérêt public qui sont
absolument insupportables 1000 questions
sur les enquêteurs européens l'Agence
européenne de blanchiment la création
d'une mission budgétaire sur la
fraudeélévation fiscale et un ou plutôt
une ministre consacré à la fraude et à
l'évasion fiscale je vous remercie merci
chers collègues la parole est à notre
collègue Thomas
Dosu pour 10
[Applaudissements]
minutes
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur ur général monsieur le
président de la commission des finances
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
avant de rentrer dans le vif du sujet
sur notre loi de finance quelques mots
sur le contexte politique particulier
dans lequel nous allons une nouvelle
fois étudier ce PLF 2024 c'est après le
déclenchement d'un n 493 cette fois-ci
très tôt dans les débats de l'Assemblée
nationale que le projet loi de finance
va faire aujourd'hui l'objet d'un son
premier véritable examen démocratique
dans une chambre parlementaire nous nous
apprêtons donc à travailler pendant 3
semaines sur ce texte faire des
propositions confronter nos visions de
l'avenir pour nos finances publiques
pour notre pays mais personne iici n'est
dupe le gouvernement incapable de
construire un compromis autour de sa
vision budgétaire fera une nouvelle fois
usage d'un 493 à l'Assemblée nationale
balayant au passage les fruits de notre
travail l'esprit chadoc n'est pas mort
tel est devenu le débat parlementaire
pour notre pays le mod d'ordre du
gouvernement pour ces débat se résume à
cet adage à l'Assemblée taisez-vous au
Sénat cause toujours pourtant les débats
qui commencent aujourd'hui sont cruciaux
les crises auxquelles fait face notre
pays se nourrissent l'une de l'autre
qu'ell soi écologique sociale ou
institutionnel vos illères votre
dogmatisme budgétaire les renforce et
fragilise notre contrat social faisant
le lit des profiteurs de haine et
entretenant l'anxiété face à l'avenir
oui ce budget est un budget
d'insouciance un budget d'insouciance
climatique pourtant le chaos climatique
frappe durement régulièrement notre pays
alors que la décru est à peine amorcée
pour les cours d'eau du Pas de Calais
laissant tout juste entrevoir un retour
à la normale lointain après plus de de
semaines de cru historique nous peidons
encore à voir les conséquences
financières de la catastrophe des
familles ont tout perdu et ne savent pas
si elles seront indemnisées des
agriculteurs VO voient leur exploitation
et récoltes menacé ou perdu des
entreprises ont dû fermer leur outil
productif parfois détruit cette
catastrophe s'inscrit dans une
accélération des phénomène climatique
extrême et ce sont les populations les
plus précaires les Français les moins
responsables des émissions qui sont le
plus durement frappés par ces
catastrophes qui n'ont plus rien de
naturel ce qu'il se passe en ce moment
c'est l'illustration de ce que
l'économiste et expert du climat nous
disent depuis plus de 20 ans plus nous
tardons à engager les changements plus
les coûts exploseront alors oui en
responsabilité nous devons inscrire
l'avenir de notre pays et donc son
budget dans une double obligation celle
d'un virage décarboné certes mais aussi
sobre de notre économie pour réduire nos
émissions conformément aux engagements
de la France mais dans le même temps
adapter d' la France son outil productif
son motel agricole ses villes et
villages pour faire face à
l'accélération des catastrophes et au
nouveau régimes climatique dans lequel
nous entrons le mur d'investissement qui
découle de cette double obligation à la
fois pour l'État mais aussi pour nos
collectivités est colossal le rapport
Jean Pisani Ferri et Selma mafous rendu
à la première ministre a eu le mérite de
poser les ordres de grandeur pour
amorcer la transition de notre pays en
respect de nos engagements je cite
l'ensemble des investissements
supplémentairire tout secteur confondu
s'éléverait à environ 66 milliards par
an à horizon 2030 soit 2.3 points de PIB
pour ce qui est de la part publique de
ces investissements le rapport préconise
de recourir pour partie à l'emprunt et à
une taxation provisoire des plus haut
patrimoine financier le ministre le
maire a balayé ses deux propositions et
ce rapport d'un geste d'insouciance
climatique qui frise le dénis concentré
sur un retour à la normale de la rigueur
budgétaire vous êtes resté sourd à ces
su g fragilisant une nouvelle fois la
parole de la France sur la scène de la
diplomatie climatique fragilisant aussi
notre contrat social qui fait peser
l'effort sur les plus fragiles quand les
plus gros pollueurs sont préservés le
besoin de recettes nouvelles le besoin
de repenser la répartition de l'effort
entre les plus gros pollueurs et celles
et ceux qui n'en ont pas les moyens
restent l'impensée majeure de ce budget
la crise sociale à laquelle doit faire
face notre pays reste forte l'inflation
reste à des niveaux élevés autour de 5 %
le gouvernement table sur une baisse à
2, 6 % l'année prochaine mais lui-même
le reconnaît le scénario est incertain
et les aléas sont élevés dans le même
temps l'évolution des salaires reste en
moyenne sous l'inflation ce qui ce qui
signifie que les Français
s'appauvrissent encore une fois ici la
tendance n'est pas homogène et votre
dogmatisme budgétaire accélère la
dynamique des grands gagnants et des
grands perdants oui vous vous êtes
attaqué ces dernières années avec
constance à nos amortisseurs sociaux les
minimas sociaux sont stables ou
augmentent trop peu vos mauvais cou
contre l'assurance chômage et les
retraites se poursuivent la lutte contre
l'extrême provvreté est abandonnée par
l'État le résultat est dramatique on le
connaît de nombreux étudiants ne mangent
pas à leur fa des milliers de personnes
dont des enfantes donent toujours à la
rue malgré les promesses les foyers même
de classe moyennees sont fragilisés par
votre refus d'une lutte affirmée contre
l'inflation alimentaire notamment pour
faire face aux conséquences social de
votre politique économique nos
collectivités nos mairies mais aussi
évidemment nos départements sont au
front pour tenir tous les bouts d'une
société qui se tend et se fracture leur
dotation globale de fonctionnement
augmente peut-être de 0,8 % mais avec
une inflation à 5 % et des missions
toujours plus variées et complexes le
compte n'y est pas nous sommes à un
moment charnière de notre histoire et ce
projet de loi de finances pour 2024
devrait être celui qui met enfin en
œuvre un changement de paradigme mais
disons-le clairement nous en sommes loin
très loin avec ce gouvernement année
après année le processus est le même un
discours volontariste des annonces une
bonne dose d'autosatisfaction on l'a
encore autendu aujourd'hui et au final
une traduction budgétaire décevante et
des résultats en dessous de nos
obligation pourtant au-delà d'une
obligation de moyens la situation
appelle une obligation de résultat et
ils ne sont pas là la faute à un dogme
une loi d'rain pour ce gouvernement
moins d'impôts toujours plus pour les
plus aisés quels qu'en soient les
résultats réels et pas de dettes
supplémentaires cette idéologie
profondément incompatible avec
l'atteinte de nos engagements
climatiques la préservation de notre
modèle social et la mobilisation des
leviers institutionnel pour y parvenir
vous vous refusez obstinément monsieur
le ministre à trouver de nouvelles
recettes pourtant les sources de
financement ou d'économie sont là plus
de 150 milliards d'Es directes ou
indirectes souvent de manière non
conditionnée aux entreprises un
patrimoine des ultrariches français qui
ne cesse de s'accumuler et de se
concentrer année après année entretenu
par vos réformes alors qu'est-ce qu'il
reste quand on refuse de se donner les
moyens de l'austorité du spoudrage et
beaucoup de communication vous l'aurez
compris le groupe écologist solidarité
et territoire regrette votre manque
d'ambition et vous proposera un ensemble
cohérent d'amendements pour un projet de
loi de finan réaliste au regard des
enjeux de notre époque et ce sur les
trois volets que j'ai mentionné
écologique social et institutionnel
écologique tout d'abord nous vous
proposeront la sortie d'un certain
nombre de niches fiscales
anti-écologiques et de rééquilibrage
fiscal entre les comportements ultra
polluants et les comportements plus
vertueux ainsi nous vous proposerons de
renforcer les capacités d'investir des
autorités organisatrices des mobilités
sur l'ensemble de nos territoires et pas
uniquement en Île-de-France concernant
votre crédit d'impôt sur l'industrie
verte nous souhaitons le muscler
considérablement pour qu'il remplisse
ses objectifs pour la rénovation
énergétique nous mettrons là aussi les
moyens en face des enjeux à la fois pour
le patrimoine immobilier de l'État et
des collectivités mais aussi pour ma
prime renove deuxième pilier sur pour
une société égalitaire et solidaire avec
un angle majeur celui de la
redistribution ISF climatique
contribution pour sur les plus hauts
revenus les patrimoines élargissement de
la taxe sur les transactions financières
les mesures ne manquent pas pour
réquilibrer les inégalités et donner les
moyens à des politiques transversales
ambitieuses et allant dans le sens d'un
changement de modèle nous proposons un
panel de mesures en faveur du logement
principale préoccupation financière pour
des millions de Français lutte contre
l'habitat indigne taxation des
compléments de loyers mesures
structurantes en faveur de la
construction de logements sociaux
dernier pilier enfin pour renforcer
notre république des territoires
c'est-à-dire donner à nos collectivités
les moyens et les possibilités d'agir
pour ça il faut préserver leurs finances
et et les dotés d'une fiscalité orientée
vers la transition nous proposerons
ainsi de revaloriser la DGF et de
composer de compenser réellement la
hausse du point d'indice des
fonctionnaire ou encore d'adapter la
dotation au département pour revaloriser
le RSA et faire face au ralentissement
des DMTO un besoins urgents nous le
savons face aux catastrophes climatiques
dû à l'activité humaine les
collectivités sont souvent l'échelon
charnière avec les 10 en première ligne
ceux-ci doivent aujourd'hui voir leurs
ressources forcément fortement augmenté
puisque c'est la sécurité civile qui
sera en première ligne face aux
conséquences de notre action collective
pour conclure mes chers collègues nous
abordons l'examen de ce projet de loi de
finance de manière extrêmement critique
vous l'aurez compris vis-à-vis du texte
initial nous nous sommes aussi
convaincus que cette exercice budgétaire
peut et doit être l'occasion de tracer
les contours d'un avenir souhaitable et
atteignable l'époque ne demande rien de
moins que des mesures exceptionnelles à
quelques jours de l'ouverture de la COP
28 le secrétaire général de l'ONU a été
clair les dirigeants doivent redoubler
d'efforts de façon spectaculaire avec
les ambitions record avec des actions
record et des réductions d'émissions au
record faisons de ce PLF celui de
l'ambition climatique record il est
encore temps je vous remercie merci
chers collègues la parole est à notre
collègue Pascal Savoldelli pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen
écologiste kanaki pour 10
minutes
progr monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de la commission des finances
monsieur le rapporteur général alors
attendez messieurs les ministres alors
je vais faire pas tout à fait comme ça
je vais dire monsieur le ministre
casenav j'ai apprécié votre intervention
parce que vous avez respecté votre
périmètre de responsabilité CELI d'un
ministre en charge des comptes publics
par contre s'agissant de votre collègue
le maire c'est pas la première fois mais
ça commence à devenir un peu
insupportable c'était celle d'un
candidat permanent ça c'est dit nous
avions proposé de de rejeter le budget
d'un bloc vous décider qu'il nous faut
en débattre dont acte nous y sommes
prêts nous présentons devant le Sénat un
budget d'initiative citoyenne constitué
de 200 propositions mais comment
appréhender une discussion d'un budget
non financé avec 145 milliards d'euros
de déficit et 200 0 milliards
d'endettement nous atteignons un niveau
record il faut parler d'une
dépendance une dépendance au marché
financiers de fait cette bulle créée par
les intérêts de cette dette produit une
fragilité de l'État ce n'est pas qu'une
histoire d'appréciation des agence de
notation ni d'injonction de l'Union
européenne pour qu' les dépenses ne sont
jamais trop basses plus 2,3 % nous était
permis au maximum quand vous prévoyez
2,6 % dans les deux cas l'inflation sera
supérieure
les dépenses publiques diminueront donc
en volume c'est factuel la Commission
européenne menacee d'engager la
procédure de déficit excessif que leur
répondez-vous la France continuera à
discréditer l'impôt et les cotisations
question l'imperceptible croissance
réduira mécaniquement les déficits
deuxème question la crédibilité
économique et financière de la France
mais aussi ses principes républicains
tels que l'égalité sont menacés par ces
décisions budgétaires pour rester un bon
élève de l'Europe la France met fin au
bouclier énergétique ceci coûterait trop
cher aussi l'énergie serait devenu bon
marché ce n'est pourtant pas le cstat
que font les Français et les françaises
dans sa déclinaison française le
bouclier énergie a représenté un coup
net de 32 milliards mais monsieur le
ministre vous avez limité la hausse mais
vous savez qu'un rattrapage est en cours
l'année dernière plus 15 % en février et
plus 10 % en août et nous nous dirigeons
vers un 10 % supplémentaire en février
le tout pour les usagers censés être
protégés par le bouclier énergétique
un/3 de la facture est prise en charge
par l'État nous dit votre collègue Agnès
panier runaché bah enfin les salaires et
les pensions à ma connaissanceces n'ont
pas augmenté
autant donc je vous le dis nous sommes
donc face à une appropriation budgétaire
par les marchés financiers et l'Union
européenne assise sur une logique de
comptabilité cela pèse en plus de la
pratique gouvernementale d'un 493
solitaire sur ce budget vous savez
l'assemblée qui perd la voix c'est la
démocratie qui est à fun l'intervention
citoyenne ignorer voire parfois réprimé
monsieur le ministre la menace d'un
shutdown à l'américaine en cas de rejet
du budget est un argument qui n'est ni
sérieux sur le fond ni respectueux sur
la forme l'article 47 de la Constitution
est clair et permettez-moi de vous le
lire dans son 3e alinéa je cite si le
Parlement ne s'est pas prononcé dans un
délai de 70 jours les dispositions du
projet peuvent être mises en vigueur par
ordonnance si besoin en était la
Constitution ne commence pas à l'article
49 ala 3 une partie de nos concitoyens
ne mangent plus à leur faim si bien que
pour subvenir à leurs besoins primaires
ils piochent dans leurs petites
économies ils veulent se nourrir se
loger se chauffer la dernière étude de
l'INS démontre bien 500000 personnes ont
basculé dans la pauvreté une pauvreté
qui se fait plus intense plus incisive
un des témoignages de cette réalité
c'est la façon dont les associations
d'aide alimentair menacent et sindigne
je cite de devoir trier les pauvres fin
de citation sur un autre registre c'est
la décollecte record depuis 2009 le mois
dernier sur les livrets d'épargne
réglementé pour 4,4 milliards d'euros
les prix de l'alimentation euut
poursuivre leur ascension vertigineuse
plus 21,3 % en août 2021 et août 2023 et
le ministre candidat permanent le maire
affirme je le cite la crise
inflationiste est derrière nous c'est
absolument indigne et nous le savons
désormais c'est étayé plus d'un tiers de
la hausse des prixs alimentaires à la
consommation provient de la dynamique
des coûts salariaux et le reste venant
entre autres des marches des entreprises
agro-alimentaires mais Monsieur le Maire
qui est déjà absent persiste et explique
je le cite qu'il n'y a pas eu de
profiteur de l'inflation dans
l'alimentaire je vous laisse seul juge
le chômage augmente l'illusion du plein
emploi coup de butoire sur la démocratie
sociale sur les travailleuses et les
travailleurs pent un bilan sombre la
croissance prévue à 1,4 % 2024 après 1 %
en 2023 n'est pas à même de résorber le
chômage elle créera de
l'intérim de mieux du RSA ça fera
plaisir au président de département et
de la misère y compris pour les
retraités là où les pensions ne suivront
pas face à l'inflation et vouloir
poursuivre le démantèlement de notre
modèle social ça a été quasiment dit
tout à l'heure notamment de l'assurance
chômage c'est mettre en danger la
cohésion nationale c'est donc toute la
boussole financière économique et
sociale qui perd le nord une politique
de l'offre ne soutient pas l'économie
elle soutient l'accumulation primitive
de capital et et nous risquons une
paralysie de l'économie sous la double
conjonction de l'inflation et de
l'augmentation du coût de l'accès au
capital si nous ne relonçons pas la
demande donc la satisfaction des besoins
en prélevant sur la spéculation toute
politique évine dans un tel contexte
sous la pression de la démocratie
sociale et le constat quand même de
l'impasse de vos politiques vous
concédez quelques quelques prélèvements
sur quelques richesses il faut le dire
ah faut dire que des organismes sérieux
le préconisent de longtemps vous savez
que c'est une aspiration forte de nos
concitoyens et je le dis ici c'est la
gauche du Parlement qui a contribuer à
ces ouvertures là et je vais faire une
autre précision ce n'est pas l'extrême
droite qui a travaillé à ces ouvertures
sur ce débat de prélever sur les
richesses la transposition de l'accord
sur l'imposition mondiale sur les
multinationales c'est intéressant mais
Monsieur le Ministre 15 %
sérieusement combien
d'exemptions combien de motifs de non
imposition il faudra vraiment être un
gros poisson pour être pris dans vos
filets cette révolution fiscale comme
certains la qualifi s'apparente à une
adaptation du Mo- 10 ans fiscal nous
aurons plusieurs amendements sur cet
article 4 pour donner toute sa force à
cet accord historique qui menace notre
modèle de société si nous en restons là
après de multiples tergiversations le
gouvernement conscent à taxer les
concessionnaires d'autoroute et les
grands aéroports depuis 2004 les
parlementaires communistes demandent la
nationalisation de ses équipements déjà
payés par le contribuable afin d'aller
chercher les 30 à 35 milliards d'euros
de Bénéfic des concessionnaires avec
votre mesure vous ne récupérez en fait
que très peu car vous fixez des seuils
de rentabilité supérieurs à 10 % pour
commencer à prélever le moindre euros
alors certes Vinc menace d'attaquer
l'état alors affirmons-le haut et fort
ce n'est pas la loi des grands
actionnaires qui doit primer mais les
lois de la République à travers la
représentation nationale le peuple fait
loi et sans cé au chantage ce budget
sera marqué par la suppression de la CV
certes échelonné mais bel et bien réelle
cela montre que les entreprises ne vent
pas en avoir tant besoins que ça si
elles peuvent s'en passer pendant 4
années vous qui nous parlez de stabilité
fiscale je regrette monsieur le ministre
vous ne vous appliquez pas à cette
doctrine monsieur le ministre renoncez à
cette césure entre l'activité économique
et les territoires dont le lien est
l'impôt en somme quelques éclaircis dans
un ciel bien sombre vous tenez le cap en
ver et contre tout et en ver et contre
tous nous irons plus loin que le
gouvernement sur la lutte contre la
faute fiscale nous proposons d'interdire
les formes de justice négociers avec les
fraudeurs qui leur permettent de s'en
tirer pour une amende en lieu et place
d'une condamnation pénale c'est le cas
de Google à qui nous avons présenté
notre proposition l'entreprise nous a
reçu et nous confirme en toute légalité
négocier de payer 1 milliard au lieu de
8 milliards personne n'a le droit à
cette
faveur personne où sont passées les
entreprises les avez-vous oublié nous
porterons donc l'indignité fiscale pour
celles qui commettent des délits fiscaux
nous proposons donc un contrebudget soit
un budget d'initiative citoyenne dont le
déficit sera significativement réduit la
responsabilité c'est d'aller chercher
les profits indus les rachats d'actions
et les versements de dividendes par
milliard et face à la concentration des
richesses nous nous proposons de
supprimer les niches fiscales le acre de
discussion avec pour aboutir à un
milliard d'euros je crois ne trompera
personne face à la pauvreté nous
proposons de bloquer les prix chacun
prendra ses responsabilités face à la
crise du logement nous proposons la
relance de la construction dans le parc
social en y consacrant une TVA à 5,5 %
tout le monde prendra ses
responsabilités face à la crise des
services publics coco nous proposons de
consacrer les libertés communales dans
la fixation de leur imposition on
prendra là aussi nos responsabilités et
notre budget d'initiative citoyenne est
juste socialement et réalisable dans son
application les 200 propositions qu'il
compose constituent un réceptable du
travail des députés qui ont été empêchés
par le 493 elle donne suite aussi aux
alertes aux alertes de la population de
l'opinion publique qui se sont exprimé
ces derniers mois donner la parole à la
Nation toute entière c'est ce que nous
proposerons dans cet hémicycle je vous
en remercie merci mes chers collègues je
profite d'un instant pour saluer les
maires et les élus de Nouvelle-Calédonie
qui sont en
tribune dans la suite de la discussion
la parole est à notre collègue Raphaël
dobé pour le groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique social et européen pour 10
minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des
finances mes chers
collègues impossible d'aborder ce budget
sans dire au fond ce qu'il est un
exercice
d'équilibriste et je dois reconnaître
que vous n'avez pas manqué de souplesse
monsieur le ministre pour exécuter ce
grand écart entre des exigences
contradictoires réduire le déficit
budget et l'endettement de notre pays
d'un côté soutenir le pouvoir d'achat
des Français et investir dans la
transition écologique ou le régalien de
l'autre pour le dire autrement et s'il
faut poser le cadre de l'exercice
reconnaissons avec lucidité que nous
sommes un peu face à la quadrature du
cercle le résultat c'est un budget que
je crois pouvoir qualifieré en trois
mots inquiétant engagé mais subit
je parle d'un budget inquiétant parce
qu'on a envie de vous suivre et en même
temps on n'est pas sûr d'avoir confiance
dans les hypothèses sur lesquelles il
s'appuie hypothèse jugée trop optimiste
par tous les experts une croissance à
1,4 % du PIB un reflux marqué de
l'inflation qui tomberait à 2,6 % une
baisse des dépenses de l'État ce qui
n'est jamais arrivé depuis 2015 une
amélioration du solde budgétaire à
hauteur de 27,6 milliards d'euros un
déficit public qui serait ramené de 4,9
% à 4,4 % du PIB une prévision de hausse
de la consommation et de
l'investissement des ménages malgré les
taux d'intérêt élevés alors que
l'épargne est actuellement le
comportement privilégié de nombreux
Français
certes vos prévisions macroéconomiques
pour 2023 se sont avéré justes je pense
notamment à la
croissance certes les bons résultats
économiques obtenus jusqu'à présent
en terme d'emploi et d'activité ont
débouché sur un réel dynamisme des
recettes
fiscales certes la nouvelle démarche des
revues de dépenses devrait être un outil
de bonne gestion avec sûrement des
économies et des gains d'efficience à la
clé néanmoins ce budget s'apparente à
une architecture complexe qui repose sur
une poutre dont on mesure mal la
résistance je l'espère nos débats
viendront l'étayer et apporter des
réponses concrète à nos inquiétudes
deuxièmement pour le groupe RDSE il
s'agit là d'un budget qui se veut
engager je dis bien qui se veut parce
que si la volonté du gouvernement de
soutenir le pouvoir d'achat d'accélérer
la transition écologique et d'investir
dans les fonctions régaliennes sont
louables il n'en demeure pas moins que
les marges de manœuvre sont limitées et
les mesures réelles ne seront à
l'évidence pas à la hauteur des effets
d'annonce ainsi indemnité carburant pour
les plus modestes est une mesure
purement symbolique 100 € par an quand
vous faites 20 ou 30 km par jour pour
vous rendre au travail c'est une somme
dérisoire attention à la question des
transports dans le monde rural l'abandon
des énergies fossil et la transformation
de nos habitudes doivent être accompagné
y compris pour les classes moyennes
attention aux bonnes idées vertes qui
déclenchent des colères noires sur des
et qui finissent sur des ronds-points
jaunes de la m façon écarter nombre de
communes du préateau Zéro est une erreur
funeste une fois de plus ce sont les
territoires ruraux qui sont
oublié le justifier par la maîtrise de
l'artificialisation des sols ne peut que
faire bondir les élus locaux engluer
dans la coûteuse et interminable
élaboration de plans d'urbanisme
intercommunaux qui sont déjà censés
répondre à cet objectif on nous dit que
ces territoires ne sont pas en tenstion
mais bien sûr qu'ils le sont seulement
les tensions sont toutes autres dans ces
secteurs combien d'entreprises parfois
des fleurons de notre industrie peinent
à honorer leur carnet de commande faute
de main- d'œuvre sans compter les enjeux
démographiques et du vieillissement qui
menacent nos services publics nos écoles
nos
commerces en revanche indexer les
prestations sociales et les retraites
sur l'inflation est évidemment une
excellente mesure de même que la lutte
contre la fraude fiscale le groupe RDSE
salue aussi l'effort proposés pour les
collectivités locales
même s'il reste très insuffisant à notre
avis au regard des besoins les communes
et communautés de communes sont face à
un défi majeur alors qu'elles doivent
s'engager par leurs investissements sur
le terrain dans une nouvelle ère alors
qu'elles sont les seuls maîtres
d'ouvrage de la transformation du pays
de la rénovation des infrastructures
sportives des écoles des monuments qui
sont parfois à bout de souffle du
remplacement des réseaux en fin de vie
alors qu'elles ont la charge de
concrétiser la trans dans les
territoires elles font face dans le même
temps à un affaiblissement de leur marge
de manœuvre en raison du relèvement du
point d'indice de la fonction publique
et des effets de l'inflation
l'augmentation de la DGF tant attendu à
hauteur de 220 millions d'euros sera
bienvenue mais largement
insuffisante sur le papier l'engagement
pour la transition écologique est
remarquable 10 milliards mais là encore
le réaliser sera-t-il au rendez-vous des
prévisions on vient d'annuler 800
millions d'euros de crédit non consommés
cette semaine sur le dispositif ma prime
renove pour 2023 et pourtant on décide
de les augmenter d'1,6 milliard d'euros
dans le budget suivant est-ce pertinent
nos dispositifs sont si complexes et
exigeant qu'il détourneent finalement
les Français de la rénovation
énergétique au lieu de les encourager à
réellement
l'entamer au final nous nous
retrouverons en fin d'année 2024 à
réaffecter des sommes colossal sur des
actions tout autre la bascule vers la
fiscalité verte et le crédit d'impôt
vers l'industrie verte auront sans dout
en revanche de vrais effets pour
l'accélération de la transition
écologique le groupe
RDSE appelle à la prudence quant à la
généralisation des budgets verts oui
valoriser les projets vertueux et
souhaitaable mais prenons garde à la
tentation de côé la vertu des actions
municipales dans des tableurs Excel et
quelle interprétation sera faite de ces
données à terme par les institutions et
la
population le RDSE salue également
l'effort consacré à l'école de la
République qui traverse une crise
d'identité très profonde alors même
qu'elle doit être la solution à
l'émancipation de nos enfants au retour
de l'ordre républicain à la lutte contre
les communautarismes et au problématique
d'intégration rien moins j'attire votre
attention encore une fois sur l'enjeu
majeur qui touche aussi la recherche et
l'enseignement supérieur il faut plus
encore pour préparer l'avenir par
ailleurs ce budget consacre des
augmentations de crédit en direction des
fonctions régaliennes défense intérieure
justice des choix stratégiques qui
constitue pour nous une saine décision
du
gouvernement troisièmement et j'en
terminerai par là inkaouda venenou ce
budget est un budget subi j'entends
parler un budget dans la Contin
ou pire un budget dans la
continuation c'est le budget d'un pays
qui peinene visiblement à se réformer
qui ne parvient pas à remettre en
question son organisation administrative
à la lecture de cette loi de finances
2024 on ne peut pas ne pas s'interroger
sur la pesanteur de l'héritage des
habitudes et du conservatisme dans nos
politiques publiques sur le poids de la
dépense publique et l'obésité d'une
partie de nos administrations qui pèse
sur le déficit public quel est le projet
de rationalisation administrative n'est
pas lisible la simplification que vous
appelez de vos vœux il est temps grand
temps qu'elle arrive on note une
prévision d'embauche en contradiction
avec la loi de programmation des
finances publiques dont certaines sont
utiles et attendus bien sûr mais
d'autres moins on s'appuie pour investir
sur un tas d'opérateurs et d'agences qui
coûtent en fonctionnement et qui ne sont
au fond que des interfaces entre l'État
et les territoires l'ambition pour la
France en 2000 30 et le cap clair et
volontariste de la loi de programmation
des finances publiques d'ici à 2027
exige des efforts d'investissement
massif et rapide des courrois de
transmission raccourcis et un délestage
courageux de tout ce qui pèse
inutilement sur l'organisation de notre
pays je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
présent notre collègue Saïd Omar wall
pour le groupe RDPI pour 5 minutes
minutes monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Rapporteur
général monsieur le ministre chers
collègues en complément de mon collègue
Didier
rambou je voudrais vous donner le point
de vue de notre groupe sur les crédits
destinés à nos territoires de
troumer je tiens à
saluer le fort du gouvernement pour nos
territoires qui souffre d'un retard
important vis-à-vis de
l'Hexagone les crédits destinés à nos
territoires doivent être
comptabilisés dans tous les missions
confondu et pas seulement dans la
mission outremè
en ce qui concerne la mission
trumè les crédits sont notoirement en
hausse au-delà de
l'inflation je tiens
particulièrement à souligner le Haos
dans les domaines suivants Haos de
compensation des exonorations de
cotisation
social avec un budget de 123 millions
d'euros
hausse de moyens dédiés à la continuité
territoriale de plus de 23 millions afin
de palier notamment à l'augmentation des
billets d'avion la hausse de financement
du logement sera historiquement haut
pour s'établir à
291 millions d'euros soit plus de 20
% on peut bien entendu au regard de la
situation concrète dans le territoire
qui cumule les
indicateurs du chômage de
pauvreté les plus forts de la République
faire le constat qu'il en faudrait
encore
plus et je
partage
toutefois il faut le reconnaître que nos
territoires ne sont pas oubliés par
votre
gouvernement j'en veux pour preuve le
deux a
exceptionnel voté cette semaine dans le
cadre de la loi sur la fin de gestion
50 millions pour l'aide à
l'enfance destiné au Conseil
Général départemental de
Mayotte et 63 millions pour faire face
contre la crise de Lou dans cet
archipel notre groupe groupe bien
évidemment apportera lors de la
discussion budgétaire des amendements
afin de compléter les dispositions
prévues dans ce budget je vous
remercie merci chers collègues la parole
est à présent notre collègue Florence
blatrix contta pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste républicain pour 6
minutes monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègue alors que
nous entamons l'examen du budget le
Programme des Nations Unies pour
l'Environnement a présenté sa nouvelle
trajectoire de réchauffement pour la
planète au regard des engagements pris
c'est près de 3 degrés supplémentaires
un scénario catastrophe en tant que
parlementaire il nous incombe d'agir
résolument dans le contexte de ce budget
chaque mission chaque programme chaque
action revête une importance essentielle
car chaque tonne de CO2 évité compte à
l'Assemblée nationale avec l'utilisation
de l'article 493 le gouvernement décide
finalement de tout tout seul nous
membres du groupe socialiste écologiste
et républicains restons fermement
convaincu que l'impératif de maintenir
un débat parlementaire exigeant
concernant la place accordée à la
transition écologique dans ce budget est
essentiel nous continuerons de défendre
un modèle de société plus durable
centré sur une nouvelle relation au
vivants et ne laissant personne de côté
la transition écologique doit être à la
fois ambitieuse et juste le caractère
social de cette transition et la
condition cinequanon de sa réussite à ce
titre nous refusons catégoriquement les
politiques publiques qui accablent les
ménages les plus précaires alors que les
ménages les plus riches ont une
empreinte carbone bien plus élevée c'est
pourtant les revenus des AG les plus
modestes qui sont les plus impactés par
les conséquences de la transition
écologique c'est la raison pour laquelle
il est impératif de favoriser une
répartition plus équitable des
responsabilités et voyez-vous chers
collègues le gouvernement n'est pas à ce
rendez-vous le budget proposé met
l'action sur le désendettement et la
réduction des impôts alors que le
rapport Pisani fer mafous commandé par
madame la Première ministre
préconise des investissements publics
supplémentaires de 34 milliards d'euros
par an d'ici 2030 pour réussir la
transition énergétique le gouvernement
ne prévoit que 10 milliards d'euros dont
7 pour le ministre de la transition
écologique 10 milliards au lieu de 34
comment pouvons-nous construire une
transition écologique ambitieuse et
juste alors que les moyens dont nous
disposons sont aussi limités
parallèlement il faut considérer que les
recettes provenant notamment des taxes
sur les énergies fossiles connaîtront
une dimission une diminution progressive
dans les années à venir et que le
ralentissement de la croissance que nous
voyons poindre euh pourrait entraîner
une baisse des recettes fiscales et
sociales pour l'État ça devrait appeler
un sursaut politique exceptionnel donc
si le gouvernement manque d'idée qu'il
prête donc une oreille attentive aux
propositions que le groupe socialiste
présentera lors de l'examen de ce budget
au travers de ces amendements car oui
nos propositions entendent prendre
l'argent là où il se trouve avec de
nouvelles recettes indispensable pour
répondre à ces défis nos propositions
prônent également une politique franche
d'aide directe et de redistribution qui
place les ménages modestes au centre de
nos préoccupations nos propositions
entendent aussi construire une société
beaucoup plus sobre grâce au
développement d'une économie de la
réparation qui génère des les emplois
verts favorise la réparation durable des
produits et stimule donc une activité
économique tout en réduisant l'empreinte
écologique France stratégie l'affirme la
sobriété le moyen le plus sûr
d'économiser de l'argent public en
permettant par exemple le développement
du covoiturage des transports en commun
et du vélo les infrastructures de
mobilité douce doivent être plus
largement accompagné qu'elles ne le sont
nous propos i entend enfin réduire les
inégalités
territoriales pour cela nous continuons
de défendre un grand plan ferroviaire
permettant la reconnexion des
territoires ruraux et le désengorgement
des zones urbaines denses également en
intégrant la réindustrialisation comme
levier nous aspirons à transformer en
profondeur notre paysage économique afin
de recréer des bassins d'emploi au cœur
de nos territoires et de revitaliser nos
villes cette démarche associée à la
transition vers une industrie décarbonée
représente aujourd'hui une aventure
collectif dont nous avons grand besoin
par ailleurs nous affirmons que les
collectivités territoriales doivent être
considéré comme des accélérateurs de la
transition pour assurer le rôle moteur
et éviter l'inertie de la mise en œuvre
concrète des politiques climatique il
est impératif de leur garantir une
capacité financière ma collègue Isabelle
briquet y reviendra selon l'institut de
l'économie pour le climat il est temps
de briser les tabout de l'endettement
des collectivités et du soutien
insuffisant de l'État à leur égard mieux
cerner le mur de dépenses climatiques
des collectivités les intégrer dans une
stratégie pluri-annuelle renforcer le
dialogue avec l'État sont essentiels
pour éviter une transition qui
aggraverait les disparité social et
territorial en ce sens nous regrettons
que le fond vert proposé par le
gouvernement reste insuffisant pour une
transition réussie un budget plus
important est indispensable en
conclusion mes chers collègues je
concède volontiers que la transition
écologique a un coût mais l'inaction se
révélera encore bien plus coûteuse sur
le long terme trouver les moyens de
financer cette transition est une
nécessité mais ce ne sera pas suffisant
il faudra aussi avoir le courage
d'interdire de réguler pour limiter les
atteintes à l'environnement je vous vous
remercie merci chers collègues la parole
est à présent à notre collègue Stéphane
sotarel pour le groupe les républicains
pour 8
[Applaudissements]
minutes monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
l'examen du projet de loi de finances
constitue le rendez-vous majeur de la
vie démocratique de notre pays qui doit
fixer le cap d'une politique les élus
locaux le savent parfaitement quand ils
présentent leur budget nos dirigeants
nationaux semblent parfois l'avoir
oublié un budget traduit une orientation
politique une volonté un chemin qui s'il
est contrôlé par notre système
institutionnel est surtout soumis à la
sanction des citoyens ainsi ce PLF comme
celui de l'année passé pose d'abord une
question démocratique adoptée à grand
renfort de 493 à l'Assemblée nationale
il n'y permet plus qu'un débat limité
même si l'en sort grossit de 175
articles si cela est juridiquement et
constitutionnellement juste c'est
démocratiquement contestable
heureusement notre bicamérisme permet
que ce débat de fond a lieu ici au Sénat
même si le gouvernement ne retient trop
souvent qu'une part congrue des travaux
que nous réalisons ce fut largement le
cas il y a un an pour le PLF 2023 ne
préjugeons pas monsieur le ministre de
ce qu' en sera pour 2024 et espérons
j'en viiens maintenant au fond à ce que
signifient les chiffres qui nous sont
soumis le PLF 2024 célèbre 50 ans de
déficit public et de quelle manière si
je puis dire tant son ampleur semble
déraisonnable la Commission européenne
vient encore de signifier à la France
qu'elle était parmi les derniers élèves
de la classe le projet de loi de
finances pour 2024 tel qu'il nous est
soumis nous livre un déficit extrême
comme le dit notre rapporteur général à
contettemps de la hausse des taux
d'intérêt que nous subissons et de la
charge de la dette qui qui est en train
d'exploser sous le triple effet de
l'inflation de l'augmentation des taux
d'intérêt et surtout de l'accroissement
de celle-ci pire encore en 2024 l'état
prévoit d'émettre une dette record de
285 milliards d'euros notre addiction à
la dépense publique à la dette souscrite
pour fonctionner et non pour investir
reste bien présente cela risque de très
mal se finir pour tous les Français je
veux ici une nouvelle fois vous vous
alerter les alerter rappelons quelques
caractéristiques fondamentales de la
copie 2024 que vous nous présentez il
s'agit d'un PLF triplement inquiétant
qui continue à précipiter notre pays
vers des abîmes d'abord un optimisme des
prévisions macro-économiques cela a été
dit hypothèse de croissance très
favorable supérieure à toutes celles
réalisé par tous les organismes
économiques indicateur toujours pris au
meilleur des possibilités cette posture
interroge sur la sincérité même de ce
budget qui pourrait encore être
davantage adé du fait d'un contexte de
resserrement de la politique monétaire
et d'incertitude grandissante au niveau
géopolitique ensuite ce PLF est
caractérisé par un déficit public qui
est le 2uxè le plus élevé de la zone
euro 4,4 % du PIB et qui représente 45,7
% des ressources de l'État la France
reste en outre le 3è pays le plus
endetté de la zone euro 109,7 points du
PIB avec une hausse de près de 12 points
depuis 2017 alors que l'Allemagne se
situe à peine au-dessus 60 points la
charge de la dette sera le premier poste
budgétaire de l'État en 2027 en
s'élevant à 84 milliards d'euros elle se
situe déjà à 56 milliards d'euros dès
2024 et encore on peut penser que
l'ensemble des facteurs qui l'impactent
pourrait la propulser plus haut encore
rappelons que le stock de la dette
publique française dépasse désormais les
3000 milliards d'euros chacun doit s'en
imprégner même la Grèce rembourse sa
dette par anticipation nous nous la
faisons gonfler
même l'économiste Olivier Blanchard s'en
inquiète
désormais enfin ce PLF acte des dépenses
publiques toujours en augmentation qui
représente 100 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires en 2 ans malgré le
retrait des mesures de crise l'occasion
de rappeler que seul l'état est
responsable du déséquilibre des comptes
publics puisque les collectivités sont
tenus de voter leur budget à l'équilibre
et que les dépenses sociales pèsent bien
moins le maintien d'une dérive toxique
du quoi qu'il en coûte avec des dépenses
de l'État toujours en Haus 22,3 % depuis
2017 est confirmé dans pratiquement tous
les ministères ce qui est peut-être
encore plus frappant dans ce PLF c'est
la création de 8500 emplois publics
supplémentaires sans réell réflexion de
fond sur nos politiques publiques et qui
ne manque pas d'interroger au regard de
l'efficacité même de nos services
publics dans tous les secteurs cela a
été largement dénoncé dans les hôpitaux
publics lors de l'épisode le plus aigu
de la crise du covid mais cela semble
aussi souvent dans l'éducation nationale
sans parler des agences et des autorités
indépendantes que le gouvernement a
multiplié au cours de ces dernières
années réduire le déficit limiter le
recours à l'emprunt passe par deux voies
possibles pour ma part je considère que
notre niveau de prélèvement obligatoire
45,6 % le plus élevé de l'OCDE après le
Danemark nous interdit d'accroître la
pression fiscale et que l'absence de
réformes structurell ne nous permet pas
encore de diminuer nos ressources
fiscales
ainsi nous vous proposerons plusieurs
pistes d'économie pour plus de 5
milliards d'euros pour tenir la
trajectoire du plpf pardon plpfp que
nous avons voté au Sénat à titre
personnel je ferai un focus sur trois
d'entre elles tout d'abord je proposerai
des amendements visant à réduire la
dépense fiscale c'est-à-dire les niches
fiscales qui représente un volume cumulé
de près de 200 milliards d'euros avec
les niches sociales et vous ne cessez
d'en rajouter davantage alors que la
Cour des comptes interroge sur leur
efficacité il convient aussi d'être
attentif avec les effectifs public qui
génère durablement de la dépense
publique il faut s'engager vers une
réduction drastique des effectifs de
l'administration administrante
c'est-à-dire de celle qui gère contrôle
norme et ne produit pas de service
publics dans un objectif de tendre vers
un rapport de 820 80 % de la masse
salariale devant élèv devant patients
devant citoyens à protéger et 20 % au
maximum pour gérer ces
services la dernière piste d'économie
consiste à réaliser une revue drastique
et volontariste de nos dépenses
publiques loin de toute politique de
rabot en commençant par les dérives né
de l'agenification de la sphère publique
et à la multiplication des doublons
administratifs du en partie à une
décentralisation ou à une
déconcentration non aboutie à ce titre
la liberté et la lisibilité de l'
doivent être retrouvé il un nouvel
équilibre entre l'État et les
collectivités autonomes et responsabl
peut et doit être rapidement établi
j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir dans le
débat mais continuer à ronier leur
autoinancement serait une faute après le
logement social ne faites pas tomber les
collectivités les départements les
épades les infrastructure de mobilité
ces quelques pistes et nous vous en
proposerons plusieurs autres pour
constituer une boussole pour une sphère
publique plus libre plus responsable
plus efficace plus pragmatique plus
proche engagé dans les transition et la
souveraineté tel que les Français sont
en droit de l'attendre un cap qui
protège mais aussi qui autorise pour
pouvoir espérer je vais terminer par une
note de satisfaction en m'arrêtant sur
l'article 7 de ce PLF qui porte réforme
des
ZRR la mise en place des FRR amendé de
manière concertée et partagée doit nous
permettre de répondre à l'attente de nos
territoires ruraux il s'agit d'un
message d'espoir attendu et pour lequel
le Sénat a toujours œuvré si vous savez
y répondre en intégrant les amendements
attendus avec pragmatisme c'est-à-dire
avec efficacité nous serons vous
accompagner et saluer cette action je
vous remercie merci chers collègues la
parole est à présent à notre collègue
Bernard delcro pour groupe Union
centriste pour 6 minutes
bien monsieur le monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur général chers collègues la
ligne du groupe Union centriste en
matière budgétaire est claire baisser le
poids de la dépense publique et
actionner davantage le levier des
recettes fiscales dans une perspective
de réduction des déficits mais aussi de
justice
fiscale évidemment la voie est étroite
entre la nécessité de réduire notre
déficite et la nécessité tout aussi
impérative de répondre aux besoins du
pays dans des domaines essentiels où
tant reste à faire la santé l'éducation
la justice le grand âge la lutte contre
le réchauffement climatique la défense
la sécurité mais ne nous y trompons pas
nous ne répondrons pas durablement aux
besoins du pays si nous continuons à
laisser filer la dette et les
déficits alors Monsieur le Ministre
votre projet de budget tente de
s'inscrire dans ce difficile équilibre
avec une prévision budgétaire ramenée à
4,4 % en 2024 tout en proposant des
crédits supplémentaires dans des
domaines où c'est absolument
nécessaire mais notre groupe considère
que pour tenir cette ligne de crête nous
devons agir davantage sur les leviers
des recettes nous pensons qu'au moment
où on demande beaucoup d'effort à nos
concitoyens le budget de la France doit
être marqué par davantage de justice
fiscale et une plus grande solidarité
des plus fortunés nous proposerons donc
une série de mesures concernant par
exemple l'exit taxe pour éviter que des
détenteurs d'entreprises échappent à
l'impôt en se délocalisant à l'étranger
parfois seulement 2 ans après avoir
bénéficié d'aide française massive les
programmes de rachat d'action qui ont
explosé ces trois dernières années les
super profits la contribution
exceptionnelle sur les hauts revenus
afin que les bénéficiire de super
dividende participent davantage à la
restauration des grands équilibres
budgétaires la rationalisation de
plusieurs niches fiscales dans un double
objectif de préservation de nos
ressources et d'égalité devant l'impôt
que Michel canvette aura l'occasion très
bientôt de pouvoir détailler le
renforcement de la lutte contre la PR
fiscale dont vous avez compris qu'elle
était chère à notre collègue Nathalie
Goulet qui a des propositions très
précises à faire ou encore le report de
la suppression de la deuxième part de
CVAE au total près de 10 milliards
d'euros d'économie supplémentaire
possible concernant vos prévisions
elle repose sur des données
macroéconomiques qui sont parfois
jugées incertaines mais comment
pourrait-il en être autrement dans un
contexte international aussi instable
et certains les jugeront peut-être trop
optimistes mais serait-il opportun pour
notre pays d'afficher des prévisions
macroéconomique pessimiste je ne le
crois pas au sujet des collectivités
locales nous savons bien que derrière
les moyennes mises en avant et parfois
flatteuses se cachent en réalité de
fortes disparités c'est pourquoi notre
groupe ne défendra pas une augmentation
uniforme de la DGF mais une haosse
ciblée sur les collectivités les plus
fragiles c'est d'ailleurs le choix qu'a
fait le gouvernement en ciblant les 220
millions d'euros de hausse de la DGF sur
la péréquation communale et
intercommunale et nous
l'approuvons cependant alors que la
hausse de la DGF était de 320 millions
en 2023 elle régresse à 220 millions une
chute de 100 millions au seul détriment
de la dotation de solidarité rurale dont
la hausse est réduite de moitié nous
proposerons donc de corriger cette
injustice en rétablissant le montant de
la hausse de la DSR au niveau de
2023 par ailleurs je tiens à saluer la
réforme de la dotation aménité rurale
que vous proposez avec des crédits
portés à 100 million d'euros en 2024
plus que doublé des critères
d'éligibilité élargis à toutes les aires
protégées et une prise en compte réelle
des superficies concernées c'est une
avancée importante réclamée depuis
longtemps par le monde rural en faveur
d'une meilleure reconnaissance des
services rendus par l'espace rural à
notre société d'autres marches resteront
à franchir dans les années à venir pour
progresser encore vers cette
reconnaissance nous approuvons également
la réintégration de l'éligibilité du
FCTVA des aménagements au FCTVA des
aménagements de terrain comme la
reconduction du fond vert qui est porté
à 2,5 milliards d'euros la décorrélation
des taux de taxes d'habitation suridance
secondaire et du fond foncier bâti qui
doivent être quand même assoupli parce
que ça nous semble un peu trop
restrictif et je m'associe pleinement au
propos de notre collègue Raphaël d'bé
sur la nécessité de rétablir le pré àau
zéro dans les zones B2 etc c'est-à-dire
évidemment dans les zones rurales enfin
nous nous réjouissons du maintien du
dispositif ZRR devenu
FRR annoncé dans le plan France ruralité
et concrétisé dans ce projet de loi de
finances un posositif essentiel pour les
territoires ruraux régulièrement menacés
des disparitions enfin pérennisé
toutefois monsieur le ministre nous ne
partageons pas certains critères retenus
comme la référence au 35e sentil du
revenu médian qui est exclu injustement
de très nombreuses communes aujourd'hui
bénéficiair pas plus que l'exclusion des
reprises d'activité il appartient
désormais au Sénat comme l'a exprimé mon
collègue Stéphane satarel au travers
cette loi de finan d'aboutir à un projet
calibré aux besoins de nos territoires
les plus fragiles notre groupe y
apportera sa contribution monsieur le
ministre vous le voyez l'Union centriste
àord l'examen ce budget de manière
positive avec la seule volonté de
trouver les meilleures solutions pour
notre pays et pour ces territoire je
vous remercie merci la parole est à
notre collègue Isabelle briquet pour le
groupe socialiste écologiste républicain
pour 6
minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues ce projet
de loi de finance pour 2024 s'inscrit à
l'évidence dans le droit fil des budgets
précédents traduisant son ancrage
profond dans une perspective
néolibérale certes quelques mesures sont
prise pour lutter contre l'inflation
elle ne saurait suffire à éviter la
précarisation d'une part toujours plus
importante de notre société ni réduire
la fracture
territoriale dans un contexte économique
et social dégradé l'État a toujours pu
compter sur les collectivités
territorial les collectivités doivent
elles aussi pouvoir compter sur
l'État depuis 2017 le gouvernement n'a
cessé de souffler le chaud et le froid
alors qu'elle porte 70 % de tissement
public en France leur rôle est sans
cesse sous-estimé leur gestion remise en
question il convient de le rappeler les
élus locaux ne sont pas responsables de
notre dette et de nos déficits publics
la dette des collectivités territoriales
ne représente que 8 % de la dette
publique totale ce qui rend d'autant
plus questionnable la contrainte
budgétaire imposée par
l'État pourquoi cette méfiance envers
nos collectivités locales et les élus
locaux rien ne la justifie pourtant il
semble que du côté de Bery il y ait
méfiance contraindre les dépenses à un
rythme inférieur à l'inflation c'est ce
que j'appelle de la méfiance cette
mesure des 0,5 % cette règle des reins
est tout aussi dure que les contrats de
caor cette contrainte peut-être perçue
comme une externalisation de la rigueur
budgétaire sur le dos des collectivités
les obligeants à adopter alors des
politiques
d'austérité la baisse des impôts de
production la suppression de la taxe
tion et d'autres réformes fiscales
coupent les élus locaux de
l'indispensable lien avec le
territoire le processus de mitage fiscal
engagé par le gouvernement depuis 2017
transforme progressivement les impôts
locaux en compensation et dotations
éloignant les collectivités locales de
la gestion de leurs propres ressources
en ne leur laissant qu'une marge de
manœuvre
réduite et le PLF 2024 s'inscrit
parfaitement dans cette logique en
plafonnant la progression des dép de
fonctionnement réduisant ainsi leur
liberté d'action les 220 millions
d'euros supplémentaires de
DGF accordé pour 2024 représente moins
de 1 % de l'inflation alors qu'une
indexation sur l'inflation aurait
conduit à une augmentation de la DGF
comprise entre 1 milliard et 1 milliard
3 cette situation met en lumière le
déséquilibre entre les attentes et les
ressources disponibles pour les élus
locaux il dénonce d' a raison une
attaque contre l'autonomie financière
des
collectivités le groupe socialiste du
Sénat portera par voie d'amendement
l'indexation de la dotation globale de
fonctionnement sur l'inflation afin de
rétablir une certaine équité
financière au final sur ce PLF 2024 nous
pouvons estimer que les collectivités
territoriales font face à une perte de
ressources de plus de 2 de 2 milliards
de d'euros cette perte résulte de divers
facteurs dont la fin des dispositif de
protection contre la hausse des prix de
l'énergie la ponction de 67 millions
d'euros sur diverses dotations et
l'absence de compensation pour la
revalorisation amplement justifiée de
1,5 % du point d'indice de la fonction
publique ces chiffr mettant en évidence
la nécessité de reconsidérer la
trajectoire budgétaire actuelle afin de
préserver la capacité des collectivités
à répondre aux besoins de nos
territoires monsieur le ministre
aujourd'hui le panier fiscal des
collectivités est quasi nationalisé en
2023 celle-ci devrait percevoir 53
milliards de fraction TVA soit près du
quart de la TVA net que se passera-t-il
lorsque les recettes de TVA seront moins
dynamiques ce sera le cas en 2024
j'imagine mal l'exécutif accorder un
pouvoir de taux de TVA aux
collectivités la question de l'impact
des taux TVA sur les finances locales
mérite un débat avec le transfert
croissant des recettes de TVA aux
collectivités locales ces dernières se
retrouvent de plus en plus dans une
position où elles finance sans avoir
leur mot à dire les décisions politique
économique sectorielle prise par l'État
cela place les élus en situation de
dépendance vis-à-vis des fluctuations et
des orientation de la politique fiscale
du
gouvernement imaginez seulement que le
gouvernement décide de diminuer le taux
de TVA sur les activités des poney clubs
et des établissements équestres
supposition et et bien les finances de
l'État pérer les conséquences de ce
choix assez particuliers tout comme les
finances des
collectivités 2024 s'annonce compliqué
ralentissement des recettes de TVA
hausse des dépenses je pense en
particulier dépenses sociales des
départements les élus locaux seront
confrontés à des choix difficiles pour
équilibrer leur budget et maintenir les
services essentiels à la
population dès lors de quelle marge de
manœuvre vont pouvoir disposer les
collectivités locales dans un contexte
de besoin d'investissement accru pour
honorer les engagements en faveur de la
transition écologique et vous pouvez
être assuré Monsieur le Ministre
qu'elles y prendront quand même toute
leur part il est urgent de rétablir une
véritable autonomie financière
reconnaissant le rôle clé des
collectivités territoriales dans le
développement de nos territoire je vous
remercie merci chers collègues la parole
est à notre collègue Olivier man pour le
groupe les républicains pour 6
[Applaudissements]
minutes monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre monsieur
le rapporteur général mes chers
collègues tout le temps passé sur
l'administratif c'est du temps qu'on
vous fait perdre ces mots je dirais même
cette consigne sont ceux du président de
la République Emmanuel Macron ceux qui
l'a prononcé il y a 2 jours lors du
lancement du programme étincelle faisons
rayonner nos
PME fil rouge de mon mandat de président
de la Délégation aux entreprises du
Sénat je souscris à 100 % à son constat
et son appel
contre la charge administrative menons
la lutte pourtant en préparant l'examen
de ce texte je me suis demandé comment
lire ce budget pour 2024 tant il est
dépourvu de mesures pour simplifier la
vie de nos
entreprises sa lecture m'a aussi laissé
dubitatif quant à l'amélioration de
l'efficacité des politiques et de la
dépense
publique ce qui me frappe le plus c'est
c'est l'absence de vision de long terme
pour notre économie et le défaut de cap
clair pour nos
entreprises le report de la suppression
de la CVAE tel que voté Parlement il y a
seulement un an en témoigne je comprends
l'impératif qui est le vôtre monsieur le
ministre au regard des finances
publiques de notre pays mais quand le
gouvernement tiendra-t-il compte de
l'ardente obligation de stabilité
législative et fiscale
pour les entreprises quand pourrez-vous
enfin offrir un cap clair solide de long
terme comme cela est demandé à tous les
dirigeants de la TPE à la grande
entreprise la délégation sénatoriale aux
entreprise plaide pour une meilleure
prise en compte des difficultés et des
défis de nos entreprises dans la
fabrique de la
loi parmi ces difficulté figure bien sûr
l'instabilité législative que je viens
d'évoquer c'est aussi nous le savons
tous le niveau de nos impôts de
production qu fois plus élevé qu'en
Allemagne de fois plus élevé que la
moyenne de la zone
euro mais il existe surtout comme l'IS
le chef de l'État devant nous cette
semaine cet handicap français sur lequel
nous pouvons agir mais nous ne le
faisons pas la complexité
administrative elle représente pour nos
entreprises une charge de 60 milliards
d'euros par an soit % du
PIB et alors que le gouvernement lançait
aussi vendredi dernier en grande pompe
les assises de la
simplification je découvre dans ce
projet de loi et ce n'est qu'un exemple
l'augmentation du nombre d'entreprises
concernées par l'obligation dite de
documentation une mesure proposée sans
étude d'impact et avec pour seule
justification pardonnezmoi l'expression
familière ça vaut son pesant de
cacahuète la mission de contrôle de de
faciliter la mission de contrôle de
l'administration fiscale en matière de
prix de transfert mais comment a-t-on pu
arriver à pareille inversion des
priorités si notre pays se souciit
d'aurit avant plus de faciliter la tâche
des services administratifs que d'aider
la création de valeur de nos entreprises
c'est que la situation est
grave concrètement une telle mesure
revient à demander à des milliers
d'entreprises de débourser des centaines
de milliers de EUR pour produire une
documentation qui dans 99 % des cas ne
sera pas lu par l'administration
fiscale je rappelle au passage que cette
dernière l'administration fiscale peut
solliciter des informations
complémentaires au cas par cas comment
expliquer une telle méfiance à l'égard
de nos
entreprises cette présomption de
culpabilité qu'à votre administration à
l'égard des entreprises monsieur le
ministre est
injustifiable enfin vous le savez
monsieur le ministre je serai
particulièrement attentif à la
conservation de l'équilibre actuel du
pacte du
trille ce dispositif est essentiel à la
périnité de notre tissu économique
constitué à plus de 50 % d'entreprises
familiales la moitié d'entre elles
seront en situation de transmission
d'ici 2030 un dirigeant sur 4 à plus de
60 ans il faut anticiper et encourager
la
transmission sinon nous favoriserons les
rachats entreprise françaisees par des
fonds étrangers ou pire les fermetures
pures et simples de nos
entreprises toucher au pacte du treuil
serait tout simplement un non sens
économique et politique la délégation
aux entreprises Pla de longues dates
pour renforcer et développer son
utilisation je suis d'ailleurs heureux
de voir que les députés de votre
majorité monsieur le ministre ont repris
à leur compte notre proposition de
relever le seuil de l'abattement fiscal
en cas de reprise par des salariés
en conclusion je vous appelle monsieur
le ministre à entendre les messages
celui du président bien sûr mais aussi
ceux que nous porterons au cours de ce
débat budgétaire je vous invite à mieux
prendre en compte l'impact réel de vos
propositions sur les entreprise
française et à remettre ce budget pour
2024 en cohérence avec nos grands
objectifs économiques ne renoncez pas à
combattre cette inflation celle des
obligations
administratives contre laquelle
Montesquieu prévenait déjà et je vous
invite monsieur le ministre ainsi que
nous tous chers collègues à méditer
dessus que les lois inutiles
affaiblissent les lois essentielles
merci merci chers collègues enfin la
parole est à notre collègue Michel
canevvette pour l'Union centrce pour 6
minutes bien monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues
notre collègue Bernard delc a tout à
l'heure démontré la ligne de notre
groupe de l'Union centriste je dirais
une position constructive mais exigeante
et tout au long de l'examen de ce projet
de lo de finance nous nous tiendrons à
cela parce qu'il est nécessaire de
rétablir les finances de notre pays
alors si l'on regarde d'abord au niveau
de la croissance on peut donner crédit
au gouvernement en 2023 il avait été
affiché une ambition d'1 % de croissance
ce sera tenu et nous disons que pour
2024 les 1,4 % constituent une ambition
réelle et c'est bien d'avoir de
l'ambition pour l'économie française et
donc nous soutenons totalement cette
ambition alors simplement il nous faut
dès à présent nous rendre compte quand
même de la situation réelle des finances
publiques dans notre pays nous avons
examiné le projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale mardi dernier ici
au Sénat je rappelle que pour 2023 ce
sont 8,8 milliards de déficit de la
branche de la sécurité sociale 10,7
milliards en 2024 et 17 milliard et demi
en 2027 c'est dire l'effort qu'il y a à
faire pour que nous retrouvions un
équilibre de nos finances de la
protection sociale dans notre pays et
malgré ces déficit on perçoit quand même
de nombreuses euh je dirais
insatisfaction dans parmi les les
personnels et tous les acteurs de de la
protection sociale dans notre pays pour
ce qui concerne l'état la situation 2024
sera particulièrement grave d'abord
parce que nous aurons emprunter 285
milliards sur les marchés financiers
c'est un montant tout à fait colossal et
après 172 milliards de déficit prévus
cette année l'année prochaine nous nous
attendrons encore à 145 milliards de
déficit et dire le chemin et cela a été
largement évoqué par rapporteur général
dans son propos à parcourir pour revenir
à l'indispensable équilibre des des
finances publiques je dirais que la
Commission européenne cette semaine nous
a mise dans la bande des quatre et nous
sommes d'ailleurs le plus grand pays de
la bande des qu c'est quoi la bande des
qu la bande des qu c'est avec la
Belgique la Croatie et la Finlande les
quatre pays de l'Union européenne où la
croissance des dépenses est la plus
importante cela n'est pas acceptable
nous sommes encore dans la bande des qu
dans la bande des qu avec la Belgique
Malte et la Slovaquie pour ce qui
concerne le plus fort déficit par
rapport au PIB cela non plus n'est pas
acceptable et vous pensez bien qu'il
nous faut restaurer rapidement
l'équilibre de nos finances publiques
d'autant plus qu'il y a un certain
nombre de signaux d'alerte qui doivent
nous rendre très attentif alors pour ce
qui concerne le chômage d'abord une
légère remontée du taux du chômage mais
nous disons que la réforme qui a été
engagée par le gouvernement pour France
travail doit nous conduire justement à
apporter un certain nombre de réponse en
ce sens et nous la soutenons bien
entendu mais nous ne devons pas nous
arrêter là car le retour à l'emploi de
nos concitoyens doit demeurer un
objectif impératif cela a été dit aussi
tout à l'heure notamment par Pascal
Savoldelli la situation de la pauvreté
dans notre pays nous préoccupe oui il y
a une part croissante de la population
qui vit sous le seuil de pauvreté et les
associations caritatives nous alertent
régulièrement sur l'augmentation des
besoins en la matière ceci doit nous
conduire je crois à ce que dans l'action
publique les actions de solidarité soit
véritablement ciblé vers ceux qui en ont
besoin il ne faut pas mettre en place
des mesures généralisées mais bien dans
chaque politique mettre en place des
mesures ciblées sur les populations les
les plus en difficulté puis autre
élément extrêmement préoccupant c'est la
situation du logement le logement c'est
quelque chose d'important tout
simplement parce que il n'y a pas
d'intégration dans la société sans un
logement il n'y a pas d'insertion
professionnelle sans logement il n'y a
pas de vie sociale sans le logement ça
veut dire qu'il faut concrètement que
nous agissions sur le logement parce que
nous le voyons bien tous tous les
indicateurs sont au rouge pour ce qui
concerne la production de logement pour
ce qui concerne la vente de logement à
présent dans notre pays et sur les
perspectives pour 2024 ça veut dire
qu'il faut que l'on mène une politique
très active nous comprenons la position
du gouvernement qui vise à réduire les
dépenses fiscales sur le sujet et nous
partageons l'idée que sur le Pinel il
faut que nous rédigions la charge pour
l'État mais il nous faut quand même
favoriser l'accession à la propriété
notamment les primau ACC accédant sur
l'ensemble du territoire national et pas
simplement sur sur les zones tendues
pour nous c'est un enjeu tout à fait
important car si l'on veut que demain le
parc locatif se réduise que la qu'il y
ait de la mobilité sur le parc locatif
il est nécessaire que ceux qui le
souhaitent puissent accéder au logement
et donc nous pensons que le prê à taux
zéro est un outil intéressant pour cela
le prêt à zéro est financé par des
recettes de TVA qui permettent justement
d'améliorer la situation budgétaire de
notre pays donc n'hésitons pas à faire
en sorte que de consacrer quelques
moyens à cela pour un retour sur
investissement ensuite qui sera tout à
fait intéressant et puis Bernard delc
l'a dit tout à l'heure les niches
fiscales il faut absolument que nous
remettions un peu d'ordre dans les
niches fiscal monsieur le
ministre il est clair que c'est quelque
chose qui est difficile parce qu'il y a
des bénéficiaires des différentes niches
fiscales mais il faut que nous ayons la
volonté de réduire et de remettre en
cause ces fiscales pour s pour se
résumer à l'Essen
voilà quelques considérations que nous
engageons dans la manière le groupe
centriste engage l'examen de ce PLF
merci chers collègues monsieur le
[Applaudissements]
ministre merci Monsieur le le président
et puis merci à chacune et chacun
d'entre vous pour vos interventions vos
questions je je me permets d'essayer de
répondre le de manière la plus complète
sans redondance parce y a quand même un
certain nombre de sujets qui ont été
évoqué par les uns par les autres
peut-être en commençant par monsieur le
rapporteur général notre trajectoire
monsieur le rapporteur général elle est
crédible pourquoi elle est crédible
c'était une sens de votre question on
l'a fait restaurer la crédibilité de nos
finances publiques on a ramené le
déficit public sous sous les 3 % mais
c'était avant les trois crises que nous
avons rencontré nous avions ramené sorti
la France la procédure de déficit
excessif ramené le déficit public je
rappelle d'ailleurs en 2018 à 2,3
2,3 % et je veux le redire c'est
peut-être passé de manière un peu
discrète mais nous avions 5 % de déficit
attendu pour cette année nous allons
être à 4,9 %. malgré les difficultés
malgré les récessions connues chez nos
partenaires européens notre croissance a
a tenu donc je réaffirme notre objectif
de 4,4 % ce qui est le plus important
vis-à-vis des Français nos partenaires
c'est de tenir nos engagements et je
préfère une trajectoire
crédible moins agressive qu'une
trajectoire qui sur le papier serait
extrêmement volontariste et qui serait
inatteignable c'est ça le sens des des
responsabilités monsieur le rapporteur
général ne regrett-ons pas la politique
du quoi qu'il en coûte au moment de la
crise je vais vous dire pourquoi oui je
sens dans vos propos que vous le
regrettez si aujourd'hui nous avons 1 %
de croissance c'est parce que nous avons
protégé le pays et nous devons nous en
féliciter quand je vois nos partenaires
allemands qui sont rentrés en réession
et le meilleur allié toujours pour
redresser les finances publiques c'est
certes la tenenstion à à la dépense j'y
reviendrai mais c'est la croissance et
c'est l'emploi et ça nous aurait coûté
beaucoup plus cher que de réparer un
tissu économique une crise sociale si
nous avions laissé le chômage s'emballé
si nous avions laissé un certain nombre
d'entreprises partir au tapis donc je
pense qu'il faut assumer que cette
stratégie était la bonne d'ailleurs été
reconnue par la plupart des économistes
en disant que c'était la bonne stratégie
maintenant qu'on on part de ce constat
là que la crise et je le souhaite
derrière nous la crise énergétique la
crise du covid maintenant nous devons
redresser nos finances pu n'ayons pas de
regret je crois que tous les
observateurs ont reconnu la crédibilité
de notre
démarche monsieur président
renal la la dépense n'est pas tabout la
dépense publique vous avez raison je
pense d'ailleurs qu'on le quand on
regarde notre modèle social je pense que
cette idée-là elle est très largement
partagé tout comme les économies
d'ailleurs tout comme les économies je
crois que ça doit pas être un mot tabou
et on est très attaché je crois comme
vous à notre modèle social mais il y a
pas de modèle social péren si on n pas
de modèle social financé et donc si on
ne restaore pas nos marges de manœuvre
et donc si on ne réduit pas nos nos
déficits nos déficits publics Rambo je
merci de mettre en avant le fait que
c'est un investissement colossal sur la
transition écologique qui est permis par
le budget 2024 et j'aurai l'occasion de
revenir dans dans dans quelques instants
c'est et et ça me permet de de de
répondre aussi à Christine lard par par
anticipation c'est le budget le le plus
vert de notre histoire le plus vert de
notre histoire alors on pourrait dire il
faut aller il faut aller beaucoup plus
loin je peux avoir ce débat il faut il
faut monter on peut aller beaucoup plus
loin et d'un autre côté on est toujours
dans dans des objectifs partager mais
mais merci Monsieur
KIC reviendrai pas sur le rapport de
jean-pisanifer celle m ma fou j'y
reviendrai un peu plus tard pour éviter
d'être redondant sur la lutte contre la
fraude vous dites il faut faire beaucoup
plus sur la lutte contre l'évasion
fiscale vous pourriez vous féliciter de
l'ensemble des articles que vous avez
trouvé dans le dans le PLF et la
sénatrice Goulet le le metaz en avant on
a 20 dispositions législatives pour
renforcer notre arsenal pour mieux
traquer la fraude partout la frotte des
entreprises la frotte des particuliers
la frotte sur Internet la lutte le fait
qu'on pénalise ce qui incite à la
fraudte fiscale qui en font le le
commerce les prix de transfert qui a été
à l'instant évoqué comme un risque en
terme de de charge administrative vous
pourriez dire ça va dans le bon sens
quand même ça va dans le bon sens quand
même 1500 personnes supplémentaires au
contrôle fiscal dans la DG FIB d'ici
2027 ça va dans le bon sens ou pas ça va
dans le bon sens 1000 personnes de plus
aussi dans les caises de sécurité
sociale parce que la lutte contre la
fraude sociale est aussi notre priorité
vous auriez pu dire également que
l'installation d'un taux minimum sur
l'Impôt sur les société de 15 % c'est
une manière de s'assurer qu'aucune
multinationale n'échappe à l'impôt sur
les sociétés c'est une conquête majeure
c'est une conquête majeure une
initiative franco-allemande de 2018 qui
trouve pour la première fois sa
traduction dans notre texte national
c'est une sacrée avancée est-ce qu'il
faut aller plus loin ou il faut aller
plus loin je vous dirai pourquoi parce
qu'il va falloir resserrer les mailles
du filet mais quand même mais quand même
madame la madame la sénatrice Lavarde je
je je vous réponds vous n'avez pas été
tendre mais sur quelques points
néanmoins bon sur les budgets verts je
partage pas du tout votre analyse moi je
suis un fervant défenseur y compris au
sein de l'État on doit en faire un outil
de pilotage pour nous on renforce on va
augmenter de plus de 7 milliards d'euros
les dépenses dites vertes il y a des
dépenses qui sont difficile à classer
vous avez raison de revenir sur sur ces
difficultésl pour autant moi je crois
qu'il faut aller plus loin on vous vous
proposera d'étendre le budget vert aux
opérateurs et dans un format je le dis
puisque certains d'entre vous l'ont
évoqué négocier avec les association
d'élus de se doter d'une boussole
commune avec les collectivités
territoriales non pas sur l'ensemble des
dépenses sur l'investissement quelle est
la part des investissements des
collectivités territoriales qui
participent à la transition écologique
non pas pour classer conditionner mais
vous voyez bien qu'on a la transition
écologique en partage il faut qu' qu'on
ait quelques boussoles communes ça en
fait ça en fait par
et vous auriez pu souligner mais je
crois que vous l'avez fait que enfin on
va se doter d'une stratégie pluannuelle
du financement de la transition
écologique grâce à un travail étroit
entre l'Assemblée et le gouvernement moi
je suis très heureux de cette avancée et
heureux que que que que qu'il vous
semble que ça aille dans la bonne bonne
direction je voudrais aussi vous dire
que je partage complètement votre
analyse sur les aides aux entreprises et
le versement des des aidees aux
entreprises vous avez complètement
raison d'ailleurs on a lancé une revue
de dépense sur cette question là la
première ministre c'est une des première
revue de dépensees qu'elle a lancé on
pourrait moi je m'interroge par exemple
quand je vois qu'il y a des aides fonds
de solidarité mis en œuvre par la DG DG
FIP d'autres par l'ASP on voit bien que
notre champ est complètement éclaté et
qu'il nous faut rationaliser tout ça
probablement aussi pour faire des
économies mieux lutter des fois contre
les erreurs et la fraude enfin vous
dites oh qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
expression du du déficit en pourcentage
du PIB aucun gouvernement aucun
gouvernement de droite comme de gauche
n'a remis en question l'idée qu'on
exprime le déficit public en pourcentage
du PIB on on ramène on ramène à une
richesse ce qui est pas choquant et je
crois pas que le parti auquel vous
appartenez n''est jamais défendu l'idée
de casser le thermomètre en en renonçant
exprimer le déficit en pourcentage du
PIB donc on pourrait au moins on peut
discuter notre trajectoire elle est pas
assez ambitieuse mais quand même ce
thermomètre là je crois qu'il est
communément admis il a probablement des
faiblesses mais il me semble que tout
parti politique confondu on s'est
trrouver là-dessus et puis la fin de
votre intervention me fait dire à quel
point c'est difficile le redressement
des finances publiques parce que vous
nous enjoignez d'aller plus loin en
disant on n'est pas assez volontariste
et la fin de votre intervention c'est le
grand âge la loi de programmation sur le
grand âge enfin vous me dites mais c'est
des dépenses supplémentaires auquel nous
en Joz vous dites les départements il
faut les aider davantage je ne vous fais
aucun je n vous fais aucun reproche
madame la sénatrice j'essaie de vous
faire toucher du doigt j'essaie de vous
faire toucher du doigt qu'il y a par
fois des injonctions contradictoires et
que vous pourriez aussi vous pourriez
aussi en être j'allais dire
victime je voudrais je voudrais
souligner à travers l'intervention du du
sénateur cap plus deux éléments d'abord
dire que je
partage naturellement la position du
groupe des indépendants sur la nécessité
du régalien vous avez beaucoup insisté
dessus et d'ailleurs dans le projet de
budget qui vous est soumis on met
beaucoup beaucoup de prior sur la
question du réalien sur les policiers
sur la justice greffi magistrat très
important et je voudrais vous dire sur
notamment la confiance vous avez insisté
dessus entre l'État et les collectivités
qui doit sans arrêt être cultivé qui a
deux sujets sur lesquels nous sommes
prêts à avancer par rapport au aux
attentes que vous avez exprimé c'est
effectivement les
ZRR et d'autre part les communes
nouvelles moi je crois que les communes
nouvelles c'est c'est un très bon
dispositif il ne faut qu'aucune commune
qui fait le choix de rentrer dans un
dispositif de la sorte soit à un moment
donné pénalisé sinon je je trouve qu'on
envoie un un signal contradictoire il
faut qu'on les encourage c'est très
courageux pour des élus de s'engager
dans ce type de dispositif il faut pas
qu'à un moment ils se rend compte qu'ils
aent perdus dans cette voilà donc sur
ces deux sujets on aura j'espère dans le
cadre de nos échanges de quoi faire
progresser le texte qui vous est proposé
je crois que la sénatrice Goulet nous a
quitté mais bien noté sur ses
propositions en matière de de frude je
proposerait de de s'associer à la
poursuite de de de nos
travaux monsieur le le sénateur d'su
j'ai l'impression qu'on a déjà eu ce
débat sur je voudrais quand même purger
un sujet qui revient de manière
lancinante sur cet excellent rapport de
jean-pisaniferri et CELM mafous que tout
le monde nous envoie en disant vous
voyez bien vous êtes complètement pas du
tout je vais vous dire le projet le
projet de budget 2024 est parfaitement
en ligne avec le rapport Pisan ferie
Salma mafous pour
pourquoi parce que quand on vous demande
et après un travail extrêmement fin en
disant il faut à peu près 30 milliards
d'euros de plus public d'investissement
public je regarde la part fait par
l'État entre 7 et 10 milliards Seon si
on est en crédit de paiement
autorisation d'engagement quand je
regarde la part attendue des
collectivités territoriales 70 % de
l'investissement public civil c'est bien
normal et elles ont envie c'est leurs
compéten qui représente donc plus de 2
tiers de cet effort que je rajoute que
je rajoute la Caisse des Dépôts que je
rajoute les C de œufs la la copie
aujourd'hui pour 2024 elle est
parfaitement en ligne avec la demande de
jean-piséniferi et C et je vais vous
dire on a un rendez-vous on a un
rendez-vous c'était l'échange qu'on
avait avec christinaavard à l'instant
c'est la stratégie plurannuelle de
financement de la transition écologique
elle doit nous aider aussi à réconcilier
C ces de grandeur et je pense que
c'était une attente du groupe des
écologistes fortement exprimé à la fois
lors des dialogues de Bercy auquels vous
avez participé et lors du débat à
l'Assemblée monsieur
salvodi alors sur le le shutdown à la
française je voudrais quand même là
aussi redire puisque plusieurs d'entre
vous ont dit ce 493 à l'Assemblée 493
l'assemblée pardonnez-moi mais notre
responsabilité c'est doter le pays d'un
budget si vous commencez et c'était le
sens des discussions qui ont débuté à
l'Assemblée en disant des groupes
d'opposition je ne le reproche pas
jeentendz jamais reprocher un groupe
d'opposition de ne pas voter le budget
on arrive non non pas du tout on arrive
dans la situation o on a risque de pas
avoir un budget puisque nous avons à
l'Assemblée une majorité dite relative
qu'est-ce qu'on fait alors si je vous
écoute il y a aucun problème monsieur
salvod dit mais il y a aucun problème
aller un peu plus loin dans la lecture
de la Constitution popularisons
l'article 47 quoi mais il renvoie
exactement le même problème parce que
prendre les budgets par voie
d'ordonnance d'abord fini la transition
écologique les grands investissements
parce que plusieurs d'entre vous ont dit
il faut de la visibilité pour les
collectivités territoriales bon courage
si on adopte le budget par 12è mais bon
et puis vous prenez le budget avec une
habilitation donnée par le Parlement et
puis une ordonnance que vous allez
devoir faire ratifier par le Parlement
qui les mêmes causes produisant les
mêmes effets ne seront pas ratifiés pour
des raisons de majorité donc votre
problème il est immense donc il mais non
mais non donc je vous redis la raison
pour laquelle je vais je finis je finis
de vous répondre monsieur sal mais je
sens un peu de de mauvaise foi de de
votre part mais je vais au bout du
raisonnement non pardon j'étais trop
loin ça
m'étonner j'ai été trop loin ouais oui
j'ai été trop loin non mais ce que je
veux dire par là c'est que la lecture et
vous avez raison c'est poser la question
qu'est-ce qui se passe il se passe que
il peut rien se passer parce qu'on a
exactement le même problème parce que
vous ne pouvez pas faire ratifier aux
ordonnances donc retour au point de
départ il faut un budget il faut un 49
en revanche et c'est votre intervention
qui me fait penser moi je suis ravi de
la manière don ça s'est passé sur le
projet de loi de fin de gestion on a
discuté y compris avec des oppositions
qui ont posé les conditions dans
lesquelles ell pourrai s'abstenir mais
sont-elles capables ces groupes sont
sont-ils capables de faire la même chose
sur un
PLF de nous dire moi je suis capable de
poser les conditions dans lesquelles je
m'abstiens pour laisser une chance à un
budget d'être voté voilà mais c'est un
sacré ça ça demande d'abord un sacré
engagement peut-être aussi du voilà
voilà une capacité de discussion et moi
je suis très ouvert à le faire mais
est-ce que politiquement les groupes
d'opposition sont prêt à nous dire
demain je suis prêt à rentrer dans une
discussion je m'abstiens sur le budget
ça serait une première mais notre porte
est ouverte notre porte est ouverte
comme elle a toujours été d'ailleurs et
enfin vous redire monsieur salvodelli je
l'ai dit sur le taux le T le taux
minimal d' c'est une avancée historique
et que le dispositif dans le temps les
mailles du filet vont se serit
progressivement mais on pourrait saluer
mais je pense que vous l'avez fait
saluer cette cette avancée monsieur
DAB pour lui répondre sur la la
généralisation des budgets verts j'en ai
j'en ai dit un mot et un budget qui
peine à à revoir son organisation
administrative je voudrais dire que le
Président de la République a confié une
mission à Eric vert sur ce sujet vous le
savez en posant cette question de
l'empilement à la fois des structures de
l'État des collectivités territoriales
la faible la faible la faible et nous
aurons et nous aurons et moi j'ai
souhaité et et je souhaite parce que
nous en disous monsieur le rapporteur
général nous n'en disposons pas nous
devons aussi évaluer combien nous coûte
tout ça et je pense que les Français ont
besoin parce que c'est leur argent de
savoir dire à Monsieur Wally pour le
groupe RDPI que merci de merci de de
mettre en avant les aides
exceptionnelles que nous avons mis en
place pour Mayotte par ce département
l'exige de notre part et et nous sommes
au côté de de ce
département madame la sénatrice blatrice
conta euh n'oublions pas le fond vert de
2,5 milliards d'euros j'entends que ça
peut vous paraître insuffisant mais il
n'existait pas quand même c'est un
effort en matière de soutien à
l'investissement des collectivités qui
n'a jamais été aussi important jamais
été aussi important alors c'est vrai
qu'on peut avoir un débat il faudrait
qu'il soit encore plus important et moi
en tant que ministre des comptes
publiques je vous dis le problème c'est
qu'on a quand même un déficit qu'on a un
sujet de soutenabilité de ce modèle que
la charge d'intérêt de la dette va
représenter plus de 75 milliards d'euros
en 207 et que on peut pas tous ces euros
qui partent dans la charge d'intér de la
dette ne peuvent pas être investis dans
dans politiqu pu donc c'est un équilibre
et je pense qu'on a absolument pas
renoncer à notre ambition en matière de
transition écologique bien bien au
contraire et on a la déclinaison de
cette stratégie à travers les COP
territorial animé par le ministre
Christophe Béchu monsieur le sénateur sa
vous réponds pas davantage sur le 493 je
pense avoir donné cette explication sur
les prévisions de croissance 1,4 je vous
renvoie le FMI nous met 1,3 la
Commission européenne à 1,2 nous on
maintient cette prévision de croissance
on ne dit pas qu'il n'y a pas
d'incertitude autour de nous hein dans
le climat international que vous
connaissez aussi bien aussi bien que
nous et je vous rejoins à 200 % sur la
nécessité de travailler sur les doublons
sur les corresponsabilités c'est la
raison pour laquelle je vous cité
notamment le travail que nous allons
lancer qui me semble indispensable et là
aussi nous sommes ouverts aux
propositions euh tout comme le travail
sur les les les le nouveau zonage ZRR
sur lequel je sais que les uns les
autres portaient des proposition et je
suis convaincu qu'on trouvera enfin je
le souhaite ici euh ici un accord et
puis vous me posez la question sur les
8500 effectifs
supplémentaire 2700 vont être dédiés à
la sécurité intérieure est-ce que c'est
trop
c'est la traduction d'e loi de
programmation je pense que vous l'avez
d'ailleurs vous l'avez voté 2000 et TP
supplémentaires pour la justice est-ce
que c'est trop je crois que vous l'avez
voté enfin l'éducation nationale et la
transition écologique dont on parlait à
l'instant en revanche la contrepartie
pour moi c'est que nous devons
travailler aussi sur où est-ce que dans
quel secteur on peut faire des économies
en terme de TP voilà et ça et ça ça nous
semble et ça ça nous semble
important quelle administration
administrante je quand je parle de
policier de magistrat duier j'ai pas
l'impression de parler de de greffier
pardon vraiment d'une administration
administrante hein pour Monsieur
sénateur
delcro vous êtes là attention aux impôts
dites on va porter des pourquoi je dis
ça pour deux raisons principales
eurostat a sorti ses chiffres il y a
quelques semaines nous sommes çaers tout
en haut personne nous dépasse en terme
de de prélèvement
obligatoire et ça ça pose deux problèmes
la piste des impôt pose un problème en
terme de pouvoir d'achat à chaque fois
qu'on ouvre la question et deux en terme
d'attractivité de notre territoire si
nous réussissons à maintenir une
création d'emploi une croissance c'est
parce que nous sommes devenus un
territoire extrêmement attractif où les
entreprises se développent et ne cassons
pas ce moteur ce modèle fonctionne
restons accroché à ce modèle qui
fonctionne ça reste notre meilleur allié
pour pour redresser nos nos finances
publiques sur la DGF j'ai bien entendu
et je suis convaincu que l'annonce qui a
été faite il y a quelques heures par la
première ministre d'augmenter encore de
100 millions d'euros la DGF qui ne sera
donc pas de 220 millions d'euros mais de
320 millions d'euros permettra je
l'espère monsieur le sénateur de
répondre aux interrogations et aux
attentes qui sont les votres et je
reçois il me reste une minute mais j'ai
terminé ou quasiment terminé si le
président accepte de me laisser
éventuellement quelques don
supplémentaires madame briquet pas sûr
les élus locaux ne sont pas responsables
du déficit de l'État c'est vrai mais en
revanche on est tous comptables du
redressement des finances publiques
parce que nous l'avons en partage nous
l'avons en partage je l'ai dit les
concours financiers pour vous rassurer
les concours financiers vont augmenter
de plus de d'un milliard d'euros et
enfin j'en termine monsieur rietman la
simplification oui vous avez raison
d'ailleurs sur la CVAE je ne sais plus
quoi penser du positionnement du groupe
LR est-ce qu'il faut la supprimer est-ce
qu'il faut laisser un lien fiscal local
dans les territoires c'est difficile à
lire je dois le dire je dois le dire et
s'agissant et s'agissant des prix de
transfert et s'agissant des prix de
transfert c'est très important dans la
lutte contre la fraude prix de transfert
prix transfert pardon je vous cherchis
je vous cherchis monsieur le sénateur je
vais vous dire prix de transfert d'abord
quand on on fabrique des prix de
transfert faut faut pouvoir les décrire
on ne demande que à ce que la
administration fiscale et connaissance
de ces informations vous êtes dans des
entreprises qui ont des filiales à
l'étranger c'est pas exactement la TPE
du coin donc je pense que c'est tout à
fait accessible et enfin Monsieur canevé
le travail c'est la clé le travail c'est
la clé pour générer des recettes
redresser nos finances publiques tout
doit être je crois dans nos dans nos
réformes orientées autour de cette
priorité et pardonnez-moi monsieur le
Président pour merci ministre la
commission des finances devant se réunir
afin d'examiner l'amendement du
Gouvernement dépose à l'article liminire
je vais suspendre la séance Monsieur le
Président de combien de temps
souhaitez-vous
disposer faites
fait pour la commission oui c'est vrai
allez on va demander entre 10 et 15
minutess bien 15 minutes allez un
maximum donc la séance sera reprise à
18h30 la séance et donc
suspendu